three two welcome everybody to the H3
podcast that's
right December 11th one day before my
beautiful wife's birthday that's
right that's
right was also saying Malik is
downstairs helping Sam with the set it
is all good vibes love to see him thank
you uh All Good Good Vibes happening
here and we're all so very excited
because this is our last week of shows
Monday Wednesday Friday and then Sunday
we are coming to you live from the world
famous Dolby Theater H3 podcast steamies
presents extravagan guests Goofs
surprises laughter throughout it is
going to be a night to remember
YouTube's sexiest night it's YouTube
sexiest
night also guys get your votes in
because um democracy matters democracy
speak speaks that's right Rock the vote
people Rock the vote uh it's I think
pinned on on Twitter and in the chat how
many votes we got coming in here Ian
here I'll uh I'll I'll start spamming in
the chat too here uh Ian's looking call
them dump what our vote count
here is it am I sh I've seen this when I
get coffee and there's like Cur like
white curds on top is that weird I was
trying to it's from the little creamer
packets but is that is that does that
mean it's bad or is it fine to drink no
it's fine to drink I just I was trying
to stir it and they just wouldn't go
always just is like cuz sometimes it's
there sometimes it's not and so I'm like
hm yeah let me know if it tastes any bit
weird I'll tell me and I'll I'll get you
a new one I fish
why we have 50,000 votes 50,000 votes
the people are speaking their mind
heard I I'm actually really excited
though it's going to be such a fun
electric show uh people coming there
will be the uh Teddy fresh um sample
sale happening as usual at our live
shows
yeah it will be cash only but I'm trying
to get a ATM next to the booth do we
have an update on that uh yeah there are
ATMs there um oh there are somebody told
me there was
okay that's good we love that I I looked
into it and they they have ATMs on site
good so uh what else we got today's
episode is sponsored by stamps.com who
we love love love love
love happy Hanukkah to all my uh Jewish
brothers and sisters out there you have
any lockas baby you have any lockas yet
yeah my mom made some yesterday but I
got to be I'll be totally honest and I
only say this because she she said it
first they were not good really she
tried to hit me with that um Mana
shevitz
bro but she tried to do what I did
remember uh-huh but she added like onion
and to it you can't add to the to
the Box pre the box is perfect as is
that's it so so something something
didn't go right something went terribly
wrong damn but we have been doing
Hanukah with the boys and it's been
super fun it's the first year we did
this with the Christmas tree and the
presents and everything it's it's it's
very very nice fun exciting
time Zach you doing anything been doing
anything for
Hanukkah been really sitick um but uh my
parents uh got me a gift they dropped it
off they got me a Lego so um a badass
Lego yeah they got me the Concord uh
airplane um which is really fun build
can you pull that up I want to see
well the Concord was like the supersonic
uh commercial jet from like the 9s but
hasn't existed is that a rare one where
do you even get that one I send a
picture of the build yeah let me see the
build that Z see the build how do you
know it's a fun build cuz I built it oh
you already built it it's done you
didn't you didn't sit on that for a
second here here it is oh get out of
here what is this just let me get out of
here okay there you go it's the oh that
is a fun build that's F iconic
build he sent a picture of his okay all
right Teddy's definitely got the Lego
bug Zach and uh I think you started a
whole Lego Revolution here be honest
very happy about that yeah uh but anyway
happy chanuka to everybody one more time
from Smokey we love Smokey Robins I have
no idea what chanuka is z you got to
pull this happy Chuka because they said
so anyway God bless you B babe and enjoy
chanuka have a wonderful time this man's
been in Hollywood for
decades chanuka this man has wished me a
happy chanuka we love him though we love
him Smokey you can't beat the the music
at a sh let's see so today we've got
whoa Zach that's like a straight Museum
holy smokes oh my God that's huge look
at that build yeah bigger in person
that's what she said uh
oh sorry
n all right thanks
everybody um we have a great show
planned today we have a segment that's
been in the works the crew is competing
to see who can create the best
uniform that's right we are next uh next
year in our new
season are moving into the utopian
not the dystopian the utopian version
where we all everybody wears the same
outfit what is that like is that meant
to be like communism where everyone
wears the same outfit where everyone's
like perfectly like homogeneous and and
like culturally identical and is that a
communist thing definitely not what
isn't that the utopian Vision no what
are you talking about everybody the same
thing no I don't think I don't think
Carl marks ever wrote anything about
that that's definitely definitely
communism Carl marks
communism Russia Soviet Union North
Korea wait hold on dripper drown dude
carks that's just a that's just a Jared
let concert that's it true right right
but an idea like that we're all equal
bro everybody's the same we all wearing
the same jumpsuit that's that's what it
is okay well that's us so the crew uh
each does designed a new uniform and we
are going to execute and deliver the new
uniform to all of us to wear all year
next year that's the only thing we'll be
wearing next year every
episode it's got to set the vibe for
2024 and we're letting the audience
decide that isn't that the idea a
terrible mistake to enforce what we have
to wear they're going to make us wear
the most ridiculous well you guys
designed it so if there's a problem it's
on you oh my God you know what I mean oh
God so that's our segment coming up here
there's also some juicy Goss in the
news I might be breaking this to an
extent I haven't seen many people
talking about it but a lawsuit was filed
by state is big news thank you State
Farm Insurance is suing David
do uh over the Jeff Whit accident more
on that
later got to keep you watching you know
what I mean oh what a hook don't be
don't be looking for those time stamps
in the in the timeline chapters no way
no way uh only cheaters use chapters
uhuh that's true uh what's state farms
uh what's their like slogan if you're a
good neighbor State Farm is there yes
that was right like a good neighbor
State Farm is there like a good neighbor
State Farm is there but State Farm is
huge man so like it's got to be a a lot
of money otherwise I don't think they'd
bother safe Farm net
worth 130 billion y'all they're coming
for you David these with
130 billion said we need to recoup from
David
dlook actually they were worth 140 last
year they they took a dip took a big hit
probably because of the Jeff W probably
yeah they're coming to recover yep like
a good neighbor yeah just like a good
neighbor here they
are um so anyway that's coming up I'm so
I'm I'm buzzing for the live though this
weekend you guys feeling excited I know
everyone's been working super super hard
on preparing everything you got there's
so much work to do with uh editing
prepping uh organizing the logistics of
it has been nuts and this is by far our
biggest most complex uh show we've put
on and this and including the space is
big and complex so there's lots of
moving Parts here going on isn't that
right guys yeah no I'm super excited my
mom's coming which is really cool I was
in she is oh that's are you going to you
she going to come backstage right uh
yeah she'll come backstage I like to say
hi bunch of our parents are coming we
need to seat them well bring them all
bring them all back we've got a great
craft service
right uh yeah bring them back feed them
let's take care of them
M I'm Mom I'm
sorry Mom I'm
sorry uh yeah so
anyway love did a photo shoot with Teddy
fresh you know how we do these and boy
it's a good time woo look good man they
fed me a good oh we bought you the Taco
Bell yeah nice we like to treat our
employees you know hell yeah good
stuff we have a series where we're
getting the crew members out there and
doing TF suits TF shoots this one with
love we and of course we went down to
Taco Bell yes sir which is his stomping
ground yeah look at that though looking
fresh and fly in the talking Bel parking
lot look at that this is a new shirt
that's out right now the pants is this
undershirt yeah it's to of fresh
everything's in fresh let's
go look at that chalupa M oh yeah that's
a good shaloma we got some little fries
there we got some little twisties in
last free but oh yeah oh yeah you know
what's up hold the phone you got a
burrito two
tacos cinnamon swirls french fries and a
quesadilla yeah holy bro you crush
all that easy
whoa it was a good time though we had a
lot of fun yeah I heard everyone had a
really good time I'm I'm that shirt on
the last picture is one of my new
favorite shirt if you go back one oh go
back like a sweater I guess oh this
one's sick yeah you look good in it too
yeah I love this shirt I've been wearing
it a lot but this this photo is Iconic
dude Taco Bell where is the endorsement
right now me this F Taco Bell never
looks so good oh that
Diablo watch out
Diablo and he here he is looking pensive
in the uh Taco Bell uh dining area yeah
just pondering on live in the Taco Bell
corner there is is this before or after
your meal this is before so you're
waiting patiently for very patiently see
but very excited very excited there
there's also kind of a vibe to just sit
and let your food digest and the talk
about dining yeah I mean I stick around
for a while yeah yeah this is outside
outside when I got the food there it is
uh we love love thank you love for doing
that very fun thank you very
fun thank you thank you know when stalos
was here
on Wednesday yeah we were talking about
Joe Rogan and he
um I knew he would do this and and and
it's he did the right thing to speak
kindly of Joe because you know like
comedians do have a camaraderie which I
think is cool I think it's nice that
they're not all trying to kill
each other like YouTubers I don't
participate in that Culture by the
way but actually they had a moment of
disagreeance on the show that he did I
think the day after or the weekend after
in which Joe was was saying some really
unhinged actually I was kind of
surprised but stavi baby friend of the
show in the most you know respectful way
possible put his foot down and said Joe
Rogan Joe time to eat a salad and shut
the up bro here he is stabby baby
he he did Joe the day before us oh he
did yeah it was like or it came out a
day before us came out a days so is it
not live no not anymore it hasn't been
live in years so he that's interesting
so they can it a few
days yeah yeah I believe
so Joe used to be live I mean that's
real it used to be live although I
I think it's been like five years since
it's been live though he still does his
UFC things live okay that makes sense
cuz it's live but I think Spotify
probably put the kibos on that the it
was pre Spotify it was when he was still
on YouTube that he stopped used to live
stream and he did he say why he stopped
I forget what it was but there was like
a
uh I want to say there was like an
incident something happened live and he
I I don't remember what it was
though find out if you can refresh
myself yeah okay so this is before
staros came on our show then that that
gives interesting context but here he is
staros first Rogan CL you see that video
there's a video that was going around
today of uh people in Chicago that are
Furious that the government is giving so
much money to uh all these immigrants
that are have illegally migrated into
Chicago no I didn't see that they're
giving them cell phone and 1200 bucks
whatever is and these people are
freaking out and you know these people
that were Democrats they're like hey if
Trump wants to talk to us come talk to
us we're tired of this and I'm like
wow this is this is wild to see these
people are waking up like why are you
giving people that aren't even from here
all this money and a free phone and all
this you're not giving anything to
us and that I mean yeah that is
it's like I think this is a
pretty juicy now actually I'm I don't
know the details of this but something
tells me it's greatly exaggerated as
these things always
are so Joe's claiming that in
Chicago illegal immigrants are getting
hooked up up is that
true I'm looking to right
now curious yeah it's I feel like it's
got to be exaggerated like the level of
welfare they're getting it always
is like in San Francisco they're making
such a huge stink about the
um the uh what do they call it
prevention where they had they pass out
clean needles and
harm reduction harm reduction thank
you they passed out like tin foil and
crack pipes and syringes I worked at one
you did for three Summers yeah where
homeless Healthcare La just down the
street oh my God was that nuts um I
really I really enjoyed it I loved it
the characters were nice yeah huh so
like people are there's a lot of
movement to get it what
happened oh there's a lot of movement to
get these shut down as it's like this
huge drain on social but the budget of
it in San Francisco is like 15 million
which I mean for the municipal city of
San Francisco is like nothing like I
wonder what's their City year uh fiscal
Revenue you know what I mean it's got to
be like a billion maybe more I don't
know San
Francisco
municipal
munici
income
yearly um I don't know I'm not going to
look it up right
now oh it says oh my God hold
on I'm not going to read it GDP of 670
billion in
2021 but that's not their their
income anyway it's 15 million it didn't
seem like that significant to me but go
go on
stavi should we restart the show
again should we restart the show again
two I'm just kidding just kidding that's
like we're seeing that's like why aren't
regular people getting that same sh why
doesn't everybody just get that why are
the IM why is that person
getting special treatment where it's
like we're just I mean that's the
safety they shouldn't get it either what
they're doing is they're trying to buy
votes that's what I think they're doing
I trying they're trying to get rid of
voter ID and they're trying to bring
people in or allow people to get in and
make it easy for them to travel all
around the country and if if someone
like let you in the country wouldn't you
vote for them but they can't vote can
they well what if they can it's it I
mean but they're talking about Joe is
really on some crazy
anti-immigrant yeah so he goes
they're trying to buy votes s's like
they can't vote right they're illegal
but what if they can but what if they
were it's like but they're not we know
they're not right I don't know where
this idea comes that like there's just
hordes of immigrants voting I mean we
would know that we there would be a
discrepancy we would know
that right yeah there there just not
votes floating around in The Ether
they're all accounted for as far as I
know uh Joe Rogan said in a Q&A that he
stopped live streaming because he was
losing money because he was getting
constantly um claimed or stried and he'd
have to re-upload the video and lose all
the views so there you go it's a good
reason you know
um what's this article here this is this
is what he was uh showing on the show
with
stos New York City's non-citizen voting
lot is struck down Supreme Court Judge
oh so actually yeah and stars did a
really good job of explaining this
too which I'll continue to play but yeah
Joe Joe I always get surprised by how
like conservative brained he's become um
this is just really crazy takes not
having voter ID like what do you think
that they were talking about it in New
York they were going to try to make it
so that you weren't a if you weren't a
citizen you could still vote New York
interesting that was something that was
discussed right I don't know cuz my dad
goog that thing about New York I think
it was discussed but I don't know that's
attempts to have people that were
immigrants capable of voting in New York
whatever you would search it under but
my dad straight can't vote and he's been
here you know 40 years or yeah 40
something if they start changing things
well has he tried hard
enough has he stolen ballots from his
neighbor I mean how do these people
supposedly vote how how is this
happening how would you go about voting
if you
weren't a how would you do that because
you have to go to the voting pole you
check your
name no no no there I don't understand
the
pipeline look why else would you want
that many people to cross over I would
want those people to cross over if I was
wanted one of two things I wanted chaos
or B I wanted vot chaos what are you
The Joker how about wanting to
help people help people you
people
Asylum give us you're poor
you're hungry dude it's written right on
the goddamn statue Jesus Christ or
more cynically uh cheap labor to exploit
chip I mean sure that that's that's also
part of a of an economy I mean at the
end of the day you possibly
so excuse me at the Joker Church
actually it's even become a problem as I
understand in Florida that there they
don't have any or not enough lowincome
workers and work is not getting done
like construction and Agriculture and
stuff like
that but um so Joe thinks that the
Democrat Party is run by Joker who's
trying to sew chaos in New York
City that's awesome
bro like that's what like wild homeless
people yeah yeah it's the same kind of
deal but also well uh here oh yeah
struck down okay state supreme court uh
judge from Staten Island said click on
it so I can read
it so state supreme court judge from
stat Island said the measure which would
have allowed more than 800,000
non-citizens to vote violated the state
constitution so they're trying to pass
this measure imagine what would be the
motivation what would be the motivation
of allowing people that are illegal
it's because we want to put poison in
the food water and then get a microwave
machine that that air uh aerosols all
the water with poison in it and then we
kill everybody in New York City wait
that was the plot to Batman Dark Knight
Rises no that was the Batman Begins
Batman Begins yeah scarecrow sorry okay
scarecrow is in charge of the
NYPD permanent legal residents permanent
legal residents so they're basically
like guys like my dad who so these are
just people that are not americ citizens
yeah yeah yeah like yeah somebody with
their green I mean some people never
like I said I don't think my dad is ever
going to become a citizen also only
applied to local so
noncitizens what's the technical term
for a non-citizen if you're not a
citizen in how can you be talking so
confidently about immigration and be so
ignorant Jesus Christ illegal
resident illegal res legal legal so do
you have a green card yes card forever
like or is it years age and residency
requirements age and residency
requirements yeah so it's like I mean
look you could debate that but it's not
the same as illegal immigrants it's like
people it's basically people that have
been in that place and they don't want
to become citizens could be able to vote
for Municipal elections not national
elections but if you are a Democrat or
if you're a republican let's see on the
other side imagine you're a Republican
and you do this and you say we're going
to let people who aren't even citizens
vote who do you think those people are
going to vote for they're going to vote
for the people that are allowing them to
vote yeah just especially if you're not
politically Savvy now he went from he
went from they're trying to sew
chaos and win presidential votes to okay
they can't vote for
president to okay well I mean listen if
you were trying to give someone the
right to vote don't you think you
support them yeah maybe you should
consider doing that yeah right May it's
like oh women don't have the right to
vote these these damn Democrats they're
trying to give women the right to vote
they're so that they're going to vote
for them yeah because they're giving
them something that they want crazy how
when you do something good for a group
of people they want to they like it and
want to support you yeah wild that's
up actually it's actually
blackmail that's actually that's
actually fascism that's political
blackmail is when people vote so true so
true oh this video is no longer
available what
happened the video we were just watching
yeah
yo let me
refresh I'm just re okay it's here so
that was weird H yeah Reddit is acting a
little funky illegal legal legal legal
so do you have a green card yeah Green
Card forever like or is it does it
expire age and
res age and residency requirements yeah
so it's like I mean look you could
debate that but it's not the same as
illegal immigrants it's like people it's
basically people that have been in that
place and they don't want to become
citizens they could be able to vote for
municip it is kind like the old it's
like Tam Hall like in gangs New
York where it's like you vote like four
times and bring the Irish people
off the boats and like put shave your
mustache and go vote again like that
kind of yeah I'm sure there's a lot
of that well that's the old yeah that's
that's how they always there's
not yeah there's not there's what's the
evidence that there's old timey people
shaving mustaches and coming back
walking around the block and coming back
and voting again is there any evidence
of this I mean there there there's in in
incidents isolated incidents of it
happening and usually they're magga
freaks they get arrested last
election ironically the one that they're
claiming was stolen uh I think the
majority of the prosecuted uh voter
fraud has been from people voting for
Trump twice absolutely oops but even
including that it's isolated it's not
it's a rare thing bro I'm sure that's
what's happening bro they come right off
the boat and we get them to vote off the
boat get them to vote Democrat
Party and to what end but chaos chaos
chaos they want to se chaos in the city
as you know all human motivation that's
a that's a baseline human characteristic
the so chaos I love doing crimes
let's do crime let's do crimes we want
the purge we're voting for that dude
that movie was sick yo I vote for The
Purge
yo awesome the thing is it's like if you
wanted the laws on voting to be more LAX
and you wanted citizens that are here
but they're not legal they're not right
you could that's but or not legal that's
next I don't think you'd be able to get
any what is what you doing staros is
like no it's not illegals it's just um
you know legal residents being able to
vote for municipal he's like no but this
is next okay fine it's not that but this
is
next it's a slippery slope bro I
literally me right I would be a person
that would qualify for that a legal
so you're immigrant you're a legal
resident you have a green card right no
I don't have a green card oh so you're
here on a work so you wouldn't be
eligible for that damn you'd have to
have a but you can get a green card I
think in a couple years yeah in a couple
years yeah mhm that's
crazy yeah we we'll stay on top of that
for you to get you the greeny thank
you green Stay Green Stay Green baby
sheesh I can go how are you trying to
get people to vote for someone who's not
a citizen voting that's always been the
thing like you cannot vote if you're not
a citizen I guess just reading off that
right I don't know anything else that to
me I don't know that I would have to
think about it but it's like what
they're what they're saying is if you've
been here a while you're a legal
resident you're part of this community
you pay taxes you do all that stuff you
can vote in local Municipal elections
you can't vote for Senator you
can't vote for president you can
vote for Alderman you can vote for
state house representative
because they directly affect your thing
which is at least a reasonable argument
as opposed to a non-citizen can have the
full legal protection yeah actually well
done staros uh in a nice
way you
know actually and shout out to The Joe
Rogan subreddit this is his I love when
his own Community shits on him 22,000
ofs Jesus Rogan tells staros that
they're bringing in illegal immigrants
and trying to change the law to give
them the right to vote stos refutes
Rogan's Claim by reading the past
article headline also says immigrant
father's been in America for 40 years
and still can't vote that's awesome
I'm not gonna read it I'm not gonna read
it yeah so shout out to Savvy baby I was
quite taken though by that claim because
that that's like really deep xenophobic
right-wing
conspir conspira toid
but he's there he's down there also
Joe is like he's like isn't he like
libertarian brain like why like the
people that live in a
place like why shouldn't they be able to
vote like why why does he have such a
problem they're stealing it just because
because they right because of the chaos
that's being so they they just want to
chaos these people vote it's like what
what really is the Hang they want to
poison our drinking water what don't you
understand yeah I love Savi good guy
turn the freaking frogs game that's wh
by the way uh just to loop back to
earlier the uh the steamies uh uh poll
is pinned in the chat now so if you were
looking for that go ahead and click that
and get your votes in lock the vote but
not if you are not a US citizen uh we
will we will actually hunt you down and
take you out well why what's their
motivation though if
[Music]
they're
yeah okay button ladies and gentlemen I
didn't hear you didn't hear me I'm
always in favor of the
button funny though yeah I love I mean
you were talking like Joe Rogan this is
um I think it was fine okay you were in
character this is uh ab's Grandpa when
he first got to America he sent this in
the Discord he's on his way to the
polling place's dad you say I said that
was my grandpa that's awesome that was
my caption straight out of Ellis Island
baby I I'm reading ab's caption don't
come for me that's awesome my grandpa
never came to
America yeah so uh there it is um what
else we got okay I know everybody is
like so over Jimmy
Lee and this is a short mention so don't
turn
off okay um he recently did that steo
post which was not met with a lot of
fanfare where it was him saying me
getting steo hooked on pills
again uh and breaking his like 20year
sobriety something really not funny at
all and we chewed him out for it right
and so the next day this is what he
posts on Instagram I
guess um oh it got removed oh no
here it is here it is I don't know why I
got removed don't
push um it is pretty mean I guess but
while I'm showing it on the show
coercing hot dog brain to relapse here's
I mean that's nuts that's crazy yeah I
can't stop coarsing people sad face
comedy comedy memes Hey Big Mike he
tagged them I've never messaged Jimmy
out of nowhere I messaged him you have
to take that down you did yeah that was
that was smart but like we all of us at
the same time were texting him well I
didn't text him I left a comment on it
though yeah but so you left one on Steve
steo you left another one on this one no
it was on this one oh if I said what I
want to say I would get
banned I said if I say what I want to
say I'll be banned from this app so have
a nice day Jim so what is it you wanted
to tell him to do damn that's cold
to uh what would he do in
Minecraft tell me in
Minecraft you
s so I mean I don't know I think Mason
really is the master troll here because
Mason's a fan of the show he understands
he has a normal work functioning brain
uh well it's meme brain for sure but
Mason I don't know if he's is he is he
trying to ruin Jimmy I don't know is he
the Puppet Master yeah I don't know he's
sabotaging
well Jimmy well you should explain what
what Jimmy said in response to so I
messaged him actually I dm'd him um he
did erase it although only at my
insistence apparently he says let's see
so this is he messaged me he said Ethan
I want to ask you want to be the co-host
for the live show next week I could come
out last minute and think this would be
a Cool vibe so he wants to co-host the
show uh this was sent on Friday what a
humble offer yeah uh I said Jimmy why do
you keep posting relapse jokes it's not
funny and people are getting
upset that was my he said should I
remove it's not steo it's Mike
MAAC he knew his name I couldn't believe
that was his response that just proves
that he had he didn't even understand
why people were mad he just thought it
they were mad because he was making fun
of steo I guess it's like okay so I got
rid of steo I replaced it with another
person it's like that's not why people
were no he's got to know man's a doctor
well I I mean know I I texted him about
the steo thing privately I didn't tell
any of you guys this I said this one
pushes a little too far for me Jim and
he responded with uh I realize I'm sorry
I took it down I honestly didn't look my
fault I just I just took it down next
time I know so and then next next day he
posts the same meme about Mike
MAA he says it's not about steo it's
about Mike MAA question question
question mark the next time he didn't
know and then he says can I come out and
co-host at the live show J it will be
the bomb and I'll have a perfect
hairline I said Jim you cannot host the
live
show okay I was hoping I understand and
I said are you okay buddy because I I
mean
I then he uh then he text wored about
him I'll see you next week I'm
co-hosting the live show he told you
that oh brother he said uh hanging in
there anyway this post is about mate
Mike MAAC just so you know as if I
thought it was about
steo he says I did take the post down
I'm sorry there you go so interesting
uh interesting thought process there by
Jimmy the Jersey Outlaw he is
dangerously
funny he's dangerously something yeah
it's all timey hey I stand outside of uh
AA meetings and hand out
drinks it's an old timey joke you
understand shoot the son of a you
ever Camp outside a rehab facility and
pass out Oxy Cotton
hey it's just a good old old timey kind
of thing all right T that's
right thank you Jimmy and interesting
tale
nonetheless um I saw
this you're going to have to tell me if
this is real or not a class system based
on eye color I believe this came from
India I saw it on I hate everything or
today it today still real to me damn it
today I hate this today what is it stand
for thanks I hate it yeah check this
out eye color cast system and this immed
IM immediately made me think of J shett
cuz him and his wife have the same color
eyes so like they're straight up doing
class Warfare like they are doing Class
cast system Warfare what's your argument
look at this would you say that this is
kind of like similar to his eye color
yeah that's him right mhm men destined
to Define eras and change history that's
not his eye color bring it we pull let's
see pull him up he's like on the third
row I'd say
a30 I don't know that's a eye hold on
let's see oh I know those eyes anywhere
trust me that's a30 that's shett nah bro
you're coping and look
influential artist and writer you're
coping brother have you ever seen eyes
like that in your life because he's got
Hazel alander the great bro this is gas
Khan he's going to change the world he's
at the top of that pyramid he's at a30
if not him then who maybe a20
maybe I think he might be A5 where's A5
it's above it's above the top you
think's he's God yeah I mean he's God
he's the a I think what is this Insanity
though if I'm being frank I think he's
A10 I think so too man destined to find
and then show me his wife too because I
want to see where she fits in men
destined to find eras and change history
who will be remembered for Millennia to
come that's J shett we will be talking
about J shett in thousands of years no
question saying D60 for him where's D60
D60 no get out of here get out of here
why would you first of all I hate J
shett and that's
disrespectful you know J shett he made
an appearance in the Press last week he
officiated Vanessa Hud's wedding oh oh
come on a Vanessa hudgin is the the like
lead from all the high school musicals
he's been officiating a lot of weddings
yeah why the are people why do who
why do people care about J shett why
wouldn't they he's so hey Jay can you
officiate my wedding he left me on
red I didn't ask him to fly out to my
wedding and do I just wanted him to say
you know
hey sorry about your eye color
condolences for being a plean
scumbag brown eyed this is this is him
apologizing to you yeah I see sorry
about that so yeah what is the story and
then here look at his wife this is why
I'm saying like there's definitely some
weird
we his wies are more
green she she's in that D row right7
perhaps so he he's dating down yeah a
bit she's very pretty but the eye color
is not where it needs to be men destined
to Define eras and change history that's
what the who made this what the is
this someone with those color eyes so
here what do what do you guys think well
oh there you go yeah well hold on before
we do that grab this other one of him
with his wife cuz this one is also very
um uh Illuminating okay if you can put
his wife and his eye colors in this
picture of them together then I feel we
can really crunch the numbers here all
right let me crunch the numbers real
quick in my eyes yeah I don't know I
mean what is this like Nazi though
yeah I know J sh I know I'm looking at
this photo I'm saying what is this Nazi
no not Jay how dare you not J shett okay
how dare you I'm
can you anyone find out the origin of
this I'm quite interested very
anti-semitic M there's blue-eyed Jews
Ela has does ELA have blue eyes yes yeah
my dad has blue
eyes there's blueeyed Jew Zach they not
as many probably as like Irish people or
some but racist it's so bad I like
that you can call anything anti-semitic
though that is a fun
thing where would I be do you think
think uh well you have dark brown eyes
so you you're down you're un I'm on the
bottom I think I'm be on this road
though no no I'm a manual labor bro I'm
not
Untouchable I'm like here
maybe so pull up my eyes we got hold on
we got to you got to do one with my eyes
too now cam yeah so the different uh
tiers are destined to change the world
like I guess Jesus or like uh
um a Athen from the Greek mythology or
something Athena what's the guy's name
who uh Brad Pit played in Troy ohes yeah
killes just like J shett philosopher
king Explorer
inventor explorers that's sick I want to
be an Explorer do I
qualify I don't know we'll have to get
your eye color up on here influential
artists writers and Generals officers
officials diplomats what is middle
management soldiers
Craftsmen manual laborers peasants
Street merchants and even below that is
oh I guess I thought it was Indian or
Hindu because of the Untouchable on the
bottom which is a Hindu cast
thing sanitation workers street
sweepers all right cam you got
me here we go oh interesting uh one of
our mods sent me the Know Your Meme page
on this which knows the origin I guess
this was from a catalog for ordering
dolls that's why they're all numbered
like that so you could order a doll with
with whatever eye color you want that's
cool cool um but then they took that
chart and turned it into this
racist screed all right so let's let's
be real here J shed's
eyes is either he's off the charts bro
there ain't nothing like him that's what
I think maybe this one is kind of
similar but it's lighter I think bottom
row third from the right is closest that
one yeah it's not see his has more blue
in it he's just he's an enigma you can't
encapsulate jhett this picture doesn't
make give his the blue collar in his eye
justice so wait it's for dolls so what
you're going to get yourself an
Untouchable Sweet street sweeper doll
they added that after well I don't
believe they were labeled that way in
the
catalog oh that's funny that was a later
Edition he's he's either this one or
he's god tier ascended I think he's off
the charts bro yeah I think he's a I
mean even his wife is kind of his wife
could be here
actually the charts God what a gorgeous
couple though stunning really stunning
my God see him in gap I go to the mall I
see him in Gap I go on Tik Tok I
see him officiating weddings I go on I
go on I go I get a nominated for
award I lose to him Jay shett get out of
my life man
[Music]
he's in car ads I turned on the TV he's
in a Lincoln ad or some BMW
your car BM he's driving my car he was
in a BMW driving my literal car and it
was advertised on the
podcast surprised didn't have your whole
family you're come yeah you're going to
come home one day and he's just going to
be playing with Theodore like he's just
he's the dad now he's taking over your
whole life he's going to hand me a sweet
Street a a street broom tell me to get
sweet man you get scrubbing brown
eyed oh God he is so detestable he is
such a scumbag no he's not so wonderful
the beautiful beautiful bright sh human
being you don't know I was in the same
room as him once I next to him I took a
photo with him I felt dark Aura I felt
Dark Energy yep you didn't feel it cuz
you didn't get close to me but I was
feeling electricity through my body like
danger I was getting why' you give him a
hug and shake his hand and smile then it
was only after there was
a a discomfort a disease that crept over
my body as I looked him in the eyes and
shook his hand I felt that Sinister Dark
Energy something really off about
him are we sure it was an envy that we
were feeling I what see I think that's
the thing is that ett's soul is so pure
and untarnished that looking at him it's
like looking into a mirror and so it
kind of reflects whatever energy you're
bringing to all that discomfort is that
what um the ghost riter isn't that what
what's his name the uh the live
forever guy said to me on
Friday about his soul being untarnished
well no he goes you asking me if I'm
afraid of death is really a reflection
of your own beliefs oh I was like bro
you're the one that's dedicating your
whole life living forever don't do don't
that don't work it's just a fancy
way you're saying I know you are what am
I I am Rubber and you are
glue um compilation of Ethan not hearing
AB thank you for putting this together
guys we can really crunch the numbers
four pills of mine so let me pull this
up here let's
see you know well you got to start
vlogging that say what chess we're
protecting the king you're the one
going what a I said it's like chess what
are the chances the button screen was
the bull what's his name Brad Brad the
bull yeah he was the be right back
button what button here's the thing I
I'm presented with the two roads one
where I just pretend like I heard him
and move on which I feel like is the
disrespectful Road I think the more
respectful road is to say AB had
something valuable to say and I want to
hear him clarify now if I heard as clear
as you guys watching the podcast I
understand everything he's saying here
bro I can you guys move this so his face
isn't like covered like I can't even see
him how am I supposed to read his list
this problem started way before this
seating arrangement mhm like years
before have you considered speech
therapy
AB maybe it's not on me I don't know
maybe I I'm I'm speaking too fast huh
what what and then it gets me in my head
because then I'm thinking about what I'm
saying I'm like how is he going to
misunderstand this and then I start
stuttering and then it just gets
worse and it's this whole cycle Jesus
man yeah I understand everything you're
saying herey for Sam what AB I saw a
post on the sub a wait what are you what
are you say when we play the
tape what what seems to be I'm actually
I feel better now I feel better already
all right good next for well I wasn't
listening I'm sorry
so didn't you uh cover passports when
you met her I understand every word
saying Ethan literally needs headphones
please no I'm not six years now I have a
solution I refuse I have a solution I'm
just going to shoot you with this I want
to talk I'm going to shoot you with this
Needler look at how cool that
thing is by the way I know I just want
to what does it shoot a Nerf it's a Nerf
G shoot me one dude that's sick it
lights up powerful I well shoot it up oh
see oh oh God my God got some gun
yo that Needler is sick don't don't hit
him with too many so when I when I want
to say something just just shoot him
sure that'll be good he's like what' you
say thank you what huh cover cover pass
like saying a cover of it is what he's
saying you sing her the pass you brought
her back to America I don't understand
the words that you're saying trying say
it again I love this one cuz I was
trying to Al you I was trying to alop
you to sing passp bro I don't can't hear
you i' take the AL if I could hear you
is his voice just in a certain frequency
range that you you have like hearing
loss in that frequency range I think
there I think that he's when he's
talking into the mic for the audience
they can hear him quite clearly he's
sitting a little bit further from me his
face is obstructed and he he mumbles a
little bit sometimes say
about half of these clips I don't I
wouldn't understand on the Fly oh thank
you love being completely honest I'm not
always got my all right all right and
that might be cuz maybe my English isn't
that good but some I have your English
is Flawless bro okay it's not that
it's I don't know
that that women's in women in
gem what did you even say they're women
in gems hilarious else got it he was
making a joke instead of women in stem
women in gem oh yeah that one didn't
make much sense to me I was just like
what are these random words I'm hearing
you say like popsicle popsicle
lemon phone him right
now what's that he's probably on the
Smith Women's in women in gem women in G
nice look how happy Dan I didn't hear
you AB did we read the caption of the
original oh my God Jesus Christ what the
God he is really such a vile little
creep is that photoshopped or is this
real I can't tell wait no you're on his
page Reddit post he posted that he
really what oh wait it's
playing thanks
AB dude he is such a vile little creep
that Kirk Charlie Kirk of the Reddit
post it said just to make sure I wasn't
talking about AB right like that vile
little creep
AB now he's the best very handsome not
vile what's the opposite of
vile the opposite of vile appealing holy
yeah appealing probably
antonym of vile be like a Angelic
Pleasant just Pleasant yeah that makes
sense what the well AB it's not
personal I really try to hear you yeah
I'm just going to I'll say from now on
I'll give Ian a q he'll switch to me and
then I'll slowly talk to the camera
that'll be good for the
show that'll be really good Dan I don't
when did you start dating Taylor Swift
dude dude whoa I thought you were in a
relationship what this
people love this post 3,000 points
they're really riding for this I'm bued
bro
the does Ally know about this bro read
the top comment
literally why would he do this to his
girlfriend Ally who uses stamps.com
so true legend so true so so true she
does yeah they also send her a digital
scale you're goddamn right and guess who
sponsored today's episode and probably
who I should do right Segway actually
it's time speaking of which stamps.com
is our sponsor today we love stamps.com
isn't that right folks we sure do I'll
tell you who else loves stamps Pro not t
Swift you think she sends her own mail
hell no she's too busy
she's too good she's too she's got a lot
going on I bet you people on her team
she is too good to send her own mail I I
she's probably got people for that but
those people probably do use stamps.com
true this is not a factual statement I'm
purely specul her Untouchable browney uh
staff does the mailing for her okay out
of context that sounds pretty bad maybe
not no yeah okay we'll take it back it's
taken back
um guys sams.com it's the holiday season
it's time to treat yourself if you are a
mailer if you use the mail if you're a
small business a large business or just
for personal if you're not using
stamps.com what are you doing cuz the
post office is just not it going there
it's a h especially around the holidays
it's so dud so nuts the parking lot the
lines the waiting the weird let's be
real there's always characters at the
post office for one reason or another
true you know but you avoid all that
with stamps.com plus even better um
benefits uh one of the benefits being
massive
discounts because of the size of
stamps.com and they serve over 1 million
businesses over the last 25 years they
get to negotiate fat discounts huge
carrier discounts 84% off USPS and UPS
rates
what 84% off yeah that's what I said up
to 84% off us whoa 84 yeah hold on if
you're going to the post office and just
mailing it you do not have access to
that kind of discount that's
everything also uh they will send you a
free scale so basically how it works is
on your computer you weigh the package
you print the postage you put it on the
package the envelope the letter whatever
then you can leave it at your doorstep
for a pickup Bob's your uncle in that
case or you can drop it off at any drop
boox all located all over the city you
can go drop it at the post office you
can do whatever you want but this thing
is you've got the option and you have
the convenience it's cheaper it's more
convenient what else can I tell you
about it I mean geez Louise man I know
somebody who uses stamps.com Dan's
girlfriend loves stamps.com
oh I wasn't going to say that but but
yeah actually she does that's a good
point yeah oh who do you know that uses
stamp St uh we could just talk about
that now that you've brought it up Ally
yeah mhm she US stamp every day just
yesterday she was the holidays are
coming up and she's got a ton of orders
and she was going nuts on the stamp.com
can you imagine went to the post office
huh can you imagine if she went to the
post office and handle that you wouldn't
see her all day she'd be gone she be she
be gone I have to start dating Taylor
Swift or something and like when's she
going to draw she's spending all of her
time at the mail post office you know
true anyway I love stamps.com I really
do they're a great company and a great
supporter of our show sign up at
stamps.com h3v for a special offer that
includes 4-week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale there's no long-term
commitments or
contracts that's right go to stamps.com
h3v thank you so much to stamps a
wonderful uh supporter of ours please
support them if you're in the business
of nailing stuff thank you thank you to
stamps.com all right they're killing it
over there
huh yeah all right what a segue huh what
a
segue what a segue um a 25mon member
just sent a thing that said I got fired
today for the first time in my life with
peace and love I'm lost that sucks oh
that sucks a whole lot Stephanie that
does suck sorry I always I have
like a phobia of being fired I was never
was I ever fired I feel like whenever I
was about to get fired I quit because I
didn't want to you felt it coming yeah I
I got fired I think just once that I can
think of and it was because I think I've
told the story on the show before but I
broke like a $20,000 light on a film set
once and it was my first day holy
uh yeah what kind of light was it 20,000
it was was a um what do they call it's
like an AR light type of thing HMI I
believe it what they're called very
expensive uh it was like I was setting
it up on a stand and something fell off
of it uh one of the lenses and I like
panicked and went to like catch that and
I did catch it but in the process the
stand wasn't stable and it fell over and
the entire so I saved the lens I broke
the entire light which is more Val they
fired me about an hour later so uh the
light was definitely more valuable
well you know it's like it's already
broken what what's firing you going to
do I mean the chances that it happens
again after that I mean I think it was
just on top like this was literally like
it was my first day and it was like two
hours into being there and they're like
all right this dude's been here for two
hours and he just cost production 20
grand let's get somebody else did you
tell them and did you go back and pick
up your pay for the two hours I did get
paid for that no actually they let me
finish the day they let me finish the
day they fired me at the end of the day
that's good yeah probably just cuz they
needed somebody and couldn't find
somebody was that day super awkward on
set for you yeah it really sucked it was
when I was like this was like a year two
after I got out of school and I was so
broke so I really needed the gig and so
it was very upsetting at the time but
now I can look back and and laugh now we
love it yeah that light well
I'm very sorry you've been
fired they you're too good for them they
suck look at it as an opportunity I
think it's decent economy though
hopefully you'll be able to find
something better huh I don't know what
your job your profession is or the
vertical but it seems like the econom is
doing decently at the moment right
uh Wes like right now to be honest it it
was good a year or two ago um it was a
really tight job market but that was a
while ago now I don't know what it's
like right
now I heard on the news that the wages
are still outpacing inflation which is
kind of crazy that doesn't even with
them cranking the interest rates like
they've been doing yeah crazy yeah oh
boy big news what is this as of November
23 the average annual salary in
California is 61,000 that actually went
up a lot from when I I remember 61,000
used to be like 50 I mean that's
California though I don't know what the
national average is it used to be a lot
less than that I mean I guess it makes
sense because California ranks nine
out of 63 States for salaries well it is
super expensive here so what
who's making the most money New York San
Francisco or well no that's California
highest average I bet it's going to be a
relatively small state I bet you like
Delaware or something if I had to guess
Delaware Massachusetts Massachusetts
that's a good board on
Monopoly those are good properties makes
sense what I mean that's just a quick
Google search though oh is that is
Delaware Street like a thing in Monopoly
it's the green part man it's like
Pennsylvania Avenue okay it's been a
long time wait till you looked at
me I'm
sorry all right thank
you should we talk about the camman
bananas Shenanigans that's been
happening it's absolutely mad sure
caman uh as you guys all know did you
say 63 States
why is every Everybody in the chat's
like 63
63,000 is the mean average income in
California you must have just misspoke
or something cuz I just seen 63 States I
what I sent him from the Google search
said 63 States I don't know what it's oh
you said 63
States we have 63 States damn that's
news to me
dude what did it say it's in the chat
still nine out of 63 States for salaries
on zp recruiter does that include like
Canada they're they're counting all the
provinces of Canada part of States
part that's part of the United
States God damn it yeah so C man's
been somewhat unhinged since our last
show he's been on the internet
um saying that I sexually harassed him
which is a lot I mean that's a big
that's a big thing to say and so on the
on the heels of that I want to defend
myself a little bit
against the very credible accusations of
Sean the guy who jerks off in public and
comes on the floor of grocery stores cuz
he's looking at people's
feet and he's so turned on he jizzes on
the floor of the grocery store in fact
saying this makes me realize we probably
should have stopped talking to him a
while ago maybe
you know the guy who says he goes out in
public and jerks off to people without
their permission looking at their
feet um I should have hearing that I
feel like this is all my fault there
something when I hear it come out of my
mouth
there um because you know all that but
anyway uh let's see here is an album of
the comments he's been leaving let's
take a look he's all over Reddit and
YouTube comments let's see oh
brother also he's been emailing you a
lot too right
Dan well I just noticed uh this morning
that he had he had sent several emails
this weekend uh demanding to come back
on the show call back into the show
which like isn't that unusual for him he
emails me all the time asking to come on
the show he came on the show last time
because he emailed me saying that he had
a funny dildo story that he wanted to
talk funny dildo story and you guys want
to know what the story was that he
bought his friend a dildo and used it
before he gifted it to
him
right that was the story he told us well
it was that uh it had instructions right
and he found it amusing that it had
instructions so he put it in his
mouth right anyway whatever yeah uh
let's see he says that it's weird it's
odd for a straight man to be fixated on
my penis I mean okay again he's the one
that calls
in to share his sex good page stories
this was a post on like this snark
subreddit which is psychotically
obsessed they've been encouraging him
cman leaves comment on Reddit saying he
did not want to share his nudes with
Ethan and he was put off by him asking I
was honestly more uncomfortable about
them asking oh this is just a a freak on
that subreddit uh here he is no means no
making it sound like I'm sexually
harassed C man I did not want to and was
a bit put off on that when I come on
there will be no more talk of my
personal assets um okay let me just pull
up a time stamp here because I felt like
I'm living in Crazy Town I think what I
think should happen here is the first
time the subject of him showing us his
penis came up C man should get the most
torqued picture of his possible you
should get yourself you should do a
little meditation you should get your
dick as hard as possible should I whip
it out now I
can show us not I did not ask in fact it
was volunteered and may I even uh
describe it as enthusiastically
volunteered to me and by the way if you
want to talk about anyone being sexually
uh harassed this man started jerking off
without you know what I mean like I I
said I want to see his dick I didn't say
I want to see him jerk off so who's the
sexual deviant I mean you know what I'm
saying these people are so desperate to
describe it like I'm sexually
harassed SE man it's it's it's it's
really
upsetting not a wreck it's not ack oh
God this is
happening oh my God his pants already
off wait how did you get as you can see
my coercion is in full display the man's
I think he broke the record for this
dick out uh pants down world
record so fast you're not in frame
you're not in frame C somebody in the
chat asked is male foot lover one C man
yeah yeah that is cman yeah that's C man
what gave him
[Laughter]
away we love C man though well listen I
I accepted him for who he was it's just
this whole weird Arc of him trying to
make it seem like I'm a sex sexually
harassed him was nuts so I'm just trying
to put things in perspective a little
bit I mean dude you jerked off I didn't
ask for
that not the same thing
bro didn't get a good look I get a good
down a bit oh okay here that's you know
I think that thing get pretty
big yeah he started to jerk off because
he was insecure about the size of it you
know he was trying to get torqued I know
what why he was doing it still something
wrong with I didn't I didn't sign up for
watching the man jerk
on you know it's a big difference in
retrospect probably should have expected
that but well and I wasn't mad about it
and I'm not right it's just the context
of all this whole ass thing yeah
you know I know what I'm getting myself
into when I bring caman
on um let's see he says I did not want
to and I was put off
really okay no means
no oh yeah all this stuff will age like
milk Ethan will pay the piper is this
his
comment this is his
comment no he's he's responding to this
comment oh oh oh this is unhinged
oh yeah all this stuff will age like
milk Ethan will pay the piper for it
eventually and I wish he'd realize that
and start treating people with a bit
more dignity it's cool to be curious and
interested and ask questions it's
another thing entirely to doggedly
interrogate someone about the size of
their genitals no matter how many times
they try to dodge the question change
the subject and then cman responded he
will get what's coming to
him what the what the man what does
that mean I don't know but like you were
begging us to call in to share your
dildo story
bro like what the man he says yes
you're right thanks it's odd for a
straight married man to be fixated on my
penis okay all right I'm not I'm more
fixated on the fact that you've been
lying about your penis size which is
funny I just find it
funny I
mean but okay sure I guess it's weird
sure where yeah
okay uh yes he just keeps saying he's
just yes you are right it's odd for a
straight man to be fixated on my penis
I'll go back on I need to get something
off my chest that Ethan annoyed me
with he says I'm fighting to help our
gay community I'm fighting for the gays
C man says that's a valuable and a
valiant fight no I'm aware of everything
I'm trying to make it big in Hollywood
so I will be tough and strong I don't
get offended but I always fight to stay
alive and
tough okay well I wish you look in
Hollywood man
yeah um I can't help but feel that this
was all encouraged and enabled by these
weirdos on uh the snark
subreddit which by the
way excuse me
um is incredible to
me I don't I never want to acknowledge
this stuff but it is pretty incredible
that on this snark subreddit these
people are so sickly
obsessed with all of us they've
literally done harassment doxing
campaigns against all of us the weirdest
thing about this snark is we had a
mod who reported I think two of their
posts one for like doxing one for
exposing uh personal information one for
harassing inciting hate and he got
banned his account got banned for
misusing the report system
but here's the kind of post that's on
this website Fallen fans attending live
here they're organizing to harass Us in
real life would be epic if you planned a
direct action in support of Palestine it
would be it would it could be starting a
chant in the theater holding signs or
banners wearing your kefas I'm assuming
it's like the scarf mhm yeah it's alive
and you have tickets your disruption
would be seen by all of us getting
kicked out would be iconic in my opinion
truthfully if I didn't live where I live
and got TI tickets for the live show I
would be getting kicked out well make it
happen if you're that if you really care
you would make it happen I don't want
excuses from you I am AOK for being
hated for being passionate then they say
if y'all want to coordinate organized I
recommend starting a signal chat and
taking it off Reddit I'm happy to help
far so here they are organizing to
harass Us in real
life on Reddit I don't think that's got
and but like we get we get
banned uh when we
when we talk about it I don't know
what's the comments there were some good
comments in this thread here's another
one of them
saying they want to organize to harass
ela's
mom who's fled EUR uh who's left Israel
she's a recent Widow her husband died
recently she's living in a house by
herself and she's been terrified to be
at home by herself with constant rocket
fire and feeling like trauma traumatized
from what happened on October 7th unable
to sleep and just really doing poorly so
these guys thought it would be cool too
and this post is still up on their
subreddit uh organized to harass ela's
mom who I guess Ela said she'd be at the
show not not Ela trying to manipulate
the audience to speak up at the live
show because her mother will be there I
don't know what the that's like
some weird that's almost like
schizophrenic like like the way that
they interpret like ela's talking to
them yep that's like the TV talking to
me type of you know like it really
is I don't even remember what Ela said
probably just that her mom would be
there yep y so then they go an even
better reason to speak up at the live
show uh truly the only Pro Palestine
people to be afraid of whenever
Palestines and their supporters show up
I don't know what you guys are talking
about I I don't know why you want to
protest my show free Palestine I'm with
you brothers and sisters you know you
know what I mean like why are you
targeting my shelf for that purpose I'm
I'm I'm wearing a pro Palestine bracelet
right now here I'm I'm protesting right
now you yes there you you snuck it in
bro hey hey you snuck that
in get that out of
here
um I do I would like to ask one of these
people if they come why are you
protesting my show I'd like to know
because I don't remember one
anti-palestinian thing I've ever said in
my life
ever I love how uh let's see I love how
uh yes uh my favorite was all the losers
on the maid sub acting like it would' be
a horrible crime someone said free pal
sign at the live show it's not that it's
that you're organizing to harass
Us in real life that's weird and
creepy by yelling things that all of us
support yeah but but none of us agree
with but that's what that's what I would
love to ask you why are you supporting
why are you protesting my show with that
I would love to ask them that did she
say this on the podcast someone said and
then they responded and this kind of
gives away that their the intention of
this is to harass her mom yes I think
today's Friday's episode I don't know
what she said exactly but I'm pretty
sure I heard her mention that her mother
will be at the live IE um eyeball
Emoji
um yeah there's really nasty in
here too poor Mama Z people saying that
they're worried now and hire security
for the live there's lots of security we
have it covered we're not worried oh
yeah no I'm not worried not a big deal I
I don't I'm not even like worried about
it happening I I I'll deal with it I'm
I'm frankly not anxious about it I'm
curious I'd like to talk to them I'm
curious to see one of these people for
real and then be like dude you you're
showing your face in public that you're
on H3 snark like that's crazy like now I
know what these people I mean that's you
that's so embarrassing
um but poor mama zus you don't know
anything about her but you see what
they're doing how they talk about her
they they really I don't
know somebody said Dan is subliminally
mess manipulating me to commit tax fraud
that's right all of you don't pay your
taxes wait what you heard me what's the
context of the tax fraud they're joking
about the subliminal messaging oh okay
the skitso posting that these people are
doing I saw a couple posts on here from
people who are no longer fans going to
the live because they paid I wouldn't
doubt that people protest there because
of some of the things he has said I that
actually if that's true that actually
makes me quite sad that like someone who
was such a fan to the point where they
bought lives and planed to come out and
then I guess they are now on this
subreddit which is like the most
unhinged freak I hope that that
that's not true I genely don't know what
I said that could cause that um also
just take this energy and directed at
somebody that's actually you know Joe
Biden was just in LA and had a huge
protest did any of these people go to
that good question you know it's like
the H3 podcast steamies that's that's
where that's where we need to the
epicenter of
Zionism Bo because ela's Mom is
there maybe I put it another way you're
a bunch of
um it's somebody said I saw this on the
H3 subreddit screenshot and posted and
then the original post said I saw it and
panicked why did you
panic but this has got to be to and like
here's the crazy part is that when I saw
this thread about like um coming to
harass Us in real life and specifically
organizing around harassing ela's mom
who's like coming here
traumatized um to escape this kind of
is
um I I I made me say redit what the
is this why is this allowed and they
don't do anything they don't care Reit
doesn't care but they don't but like so
Trisha had a snark subreddit that got
like nuked out of existence mhm but like
I don't know why they I I I well
usually I I don't know how long this has
been around cuz I I try not to pay
attention to this but usually it
takes a while like famously that
um I mean this is ancient history on
Reddit now but there was like this
horrible subreddit called jail bait that
was literally a p subreddit and it was
on the website for years I remember that
and everyone was always pointing it out
and complaining about it or whatever and
it wasn't until it made it to mainstream
news and like the next day that was
gone so that was one of the biggest
subreddits it was and so I think that's
that's kind of their attitude is until
like it actually is you know
upsetting it's it's kind of hitting the
mainstream and it's going to potentially
affect advertisers and stuff they just
take a hands-off approach they just
don't know the
care I mean the jailbait one is not that
would I would be on all browsing all and
it's on my
homepage uh I started using Reddit right
at the end of that era so I never
actually experienced that but I I
remember hearing about that whole drama
and there's been a few more cycles of
that too I mean they do take action you
know it happens like you just said
Trisha had like a harassing subredit
like this and they eventually did get
rid of it right I don't know for what or
W yeah and she had a subreddit that was
like populated by really obsessive
weirdos too cuz the the purpose of the
snark uh subreddits is literally like
um to inight harassment and hate like
that's it I don't there's no there's no
like I'm surprised these snark sub rats
are even allowed because it just seems
like they all devolved into really nasty
dude I don't know super invasive
and like just creepy and weird but
um somebody said I think Trisha sent
lawyers I mean maybe maybe and that's
exactly it's just like I don't think
reporting it to Reddit will do anything
if they get a letter from a lawyer they
might actually do something silver
phenomenon says the CEO of Reddit was a
mod of jail
bait doesn't surprise me
dude could it be that they just added
him but that he that means he knows
about it oh they were certainly aware
well like I said it was on my it was on
my all feet it was definitely aware but
um yeah anyway I think that this
is super up like there's lots of
really nasty and that stuff's
whatever I don't care about it but when
I really when I saw this post about
harassing ela's mom was when I was like
I should I should say something cuz this
is too far this is too much you
know
so it's it's looking like you're right
that they uh they made him a mod without
him knowing but I think I don't know if
it changed but you have to
accept to be a
mod uhbe do you I'm trying to remember
if when uh the AR Kanye subreddit added
me as a mod which I'm still a mod of by
the way um if I had to accept that or
not that's the only time in recent
memory that I've been invited to do that
I'm pretty sure you have to accept I
think I'm still on there let me check
yeah AR
[Music]
Kane I saw I just saw Love's message in
Discord delayed and I'm like what the
is love talking about but that's
old now he's talking about C man he goes
he was trying to get torque to be fair
dude they removed me oh no Kanye
West dude Nazi piece of
no Ian are you still on there no
remember that was the whole thing they
removed Ian and they added me instead
there's a fan and that's that's awesome
yeah there is uh but maybe maybe not
anymore it looks like they actually
purged most of the moderator oh I heard
they closed it right Ian and protest
like they had to they had to abandon uh
that was like I think they're over it I
think they're they're back on the Kanye
train over there I don't know oh they're
back yeah there but there's it's dude
there's like three H3 snark subreddits
there's like three yeah there's
Frenemies three and then H3 H3
underscore which is the one that Matt
hos made is my conspiracy long
ago and then there's the um that one I
remember snark one but I haven't you
should look at the like I don't I don't
look at them and the other two I have
never cared about but these posts from
this specific subreddit I did care about
sure I mean that's that's why I'm
talking about it I was like yo man the
off all that yeah it's pretty
nasty uh there it is social media in
general man it's just it's just bad bad
for your brain really is oh wait there
was more cman stuff um I just want to
make sure I talk about it all and then
there's the one of
him I asked him they saying IED him to
post it on Twitter and but so the
there's a picture one and so here is me
asking if I can post it on Twitter so
that the audience knew what we were
talking about public video that you made
it's you with two dudes and you all are
having a good time and you pan down to
your dick real fast so that's the photo
is going to ask for your permission if I
could post it to Twitter so that the
fans can share their opinion on the size
of it they want to share the opinion
that's fine I don't mind you could do it
it is and so I
mean yeah I mean listen it's an
appropriate question I I think you could
say uh it's a he I mean the guy is has
his dick out publicly on public
subreddit so I
mean I asked permission and he said yes
I mean he he said yes I don't know what
to say well yeah and again like you said
you met him by him making an aded for
his website for his adult website so
exactly that's how we found him because
he was trying to recruit people for his
foot fetish website on YouTube yeah if
it was like he posted his his own dick
on Twitter apparently uh too I don't
know I don't know but look I'll say this
I mean yeah he's he does porn like it's
it's all very public it would be a
totally different story if this was even
if it was porn but it was behind a pay
wall or something uh and it wasn't like
publicly available you know that gets
into a much grayer territory but this is
stuff that he I think it's it was it he
posted it on Reddit right yeah he has
his own subreddit where he post this
that's where we found it so this it's
all publicly available material like and
I'm not trying to say like because he's
a adult performer that therefore it
doesn't matter no you still ask for
permission these people you know that's
not my opinion on that at all but I
asked permission and he he gave it
pretty again uh emphatically share their
opinion immed the size of it they want
to share the opinion that's fine I don't
mind you could do it just thank you like
I said is the whole the whole whole
thing with me was I just went off with
someone told me like I said I've never
measured it I don't and then it's clear
when you watch his hesitancy is just
because it doesn't look big and he wants
it to look big which is why he offered a
little bit after this he says I'll come
I'll go come back in 10 minutes I'll go
jerk off and then I'll show you my
erection so you know that was his offer
to us and uh I find listen and I'll say
this and somebody said now that he's
removed consent did you remove the
picture yeah we deleted it I deleted it
if I I didn't know it bothered him when
I found out I erased it you know what I
mean public nudity calls are interesting
but I'll say this you know first of all
like I um I put myself in this
position and that's where I'll say that
this that I up this is this is
you know this is a old timey kind of
shock humor doesn't really translate
well today and I put myself and it was
it was it got pretty
outrageous uh I wasn't immediate I
remember Ethan asked multiple times
before and after he said no here watch
this don't go opinion on this mission
video
that I wasn't
AR never turned on understand so the
there's a picture one public video that
you made it's you with two dudes and you
all are having a good time and you pan
down to your real fast so that's the
photo going to ask for your permission
if I could post it to Twitter so that
the fans can share their opinion on the
size of it they want to share the Pet's
fine I don't mind you could do it just
that's it that was the whole thing um
people okay can you hold on one
sec you freak I'm just Banning
some weird by
dummy um anyway I was just replying to
that person to tell him to shut up she
keeps spanning the same dumb sh
up dude shut the up Amy so
like obviously you know I put myself
into this weird position people are
saying power Dynamic why I don't know
what you want I he calls into the show
because to explain his sexcapades you
know like okay sure but that's what I'm
saying I put myself in this position it
was uh turned into something awkward and
bad and I I'm not doing this
anymore okay so that's it male foot
lover one I'll give him one last plug
for the road there's any investors out
there looking to
invest yeah that'll be the end of the C
man I mean I even I even sent the man a
picture of my me driving Barefoot man or
video sent him a video of me driving
Barefoot come
on you know
lot people saying they never really like
C man so maybe it's for the best well
that that Arc is definitely over with
peace and love but I guess yeah I think
it did get pretty extreme there talking
about like jerking off and showing it it
went too far it did go too far and when
it goes too far it puts in a position
where I
compromising uh myself right and so
whatever thank you that's what I'll say
about C
man but uh best of luck to you I mean
he's you
know he's out there what happened should
have happened what should have happened
happened and it is what it is that's
kind of true isn't it so that's the cman
followup time stamp uh
yeah Goofs and G salutes in the chat I
see that one last salute salute to the
Sean Saga oh we're saying yeah we're
saying byebye to C man dude there they
really is the H3 guest curse because we
talked
to the live forever guy oh Brian Johnson
MH we talked to him on Friday right and
this weekend a story came out about him
of one of his ex's suing
him for
abuse mhm the s the day after bro people
can and then same thing happened to
dream you can't escape dream was like it
was like the last minute of the episode
I think yes and I saw him trending on
Twitter I'm like no way no way I'm can
you believe and I I keep joking about
the H3 curse but like it keeps being
proven and and you know it makes me
worried about having people call in at
all I don't think we can have guests
anymore
period cuz I don't at this point I think
when we have a guest it opens up a
portal to alternate universe where
they're like a predator right cuz at
this point the chances of them all just
being exposed to as Predators one day
after the show is too it's too
astronomical so it's us doing it to them
thank you
Zach it makes me worried about the
reoccurring guest like we think Jimmy's
bad but I mean I don't know maybe he has
like bodies in his basement or something
yeah I mean
that ah Jimmy we love Jimmy
we love Jimmy that's I'm gonna have a
hard time letting Jimmy go he's my
dog we got each other's backs me and
Jimmy you know it's about
loyalty oh see he was also threatening
to sue me I guess he said uh I wonder
what his legal team thinks by the way I
think I might need to figure things out
legally okay
what that' be an epic deposition all the
all the talk about his dick size oh God
yeah he's like he defame me your on he
said my dick is
small exhibit a your lawyer would need
like the national
average true exhibit a your honor is a
picture of Seaman's uh penis from the
video entitled just a couple of dudes
having fun in the classroom after
dark here is exhibit B C man saying his
penis is in between somewhere in between
9 and 12 in ladies and gentlemen the
jury I present
you exhibit a and exhibit
B it is not lining up your honor clearly
this man does not have a 9-in penis it
is clear to all of you members of the
jury here's a 9in penis your honor
here's what a fled 9-in penis looks like
your
honor and here's every stage of
erection you can clearly see lining it
up with C man's C that in no part of
this erection life cycle does caman
enter into the
equation he's going to say you can't
handle the truth and rip it pull his
take out in front
of and they just got a hog and then the
court got they
gas yeah then you're going to have to
pay up somehow get it
there yeah I don't know it sucks I feel
I feel bad that this whole thing went
sideways but it is what it is an innate
one
Ain that's what it is that's the way the
cookie that's the way the egg you
sometimes you got to BR break an egg to
make a to make an omelette and in order
to comprehend you're going to have to
break
some comprehend in order to comprehend
and to eat the the the the omelet of
knowledge you're going to need to break
those eggshells exactly he took the
words right out of my
mouth um there it is is thank you Kylie
Crum
says I'll I'll read all the donut and
stuff at the end we've had a good uh
Habit of doing that so I don't miss
anything here's some fun stuff cavcav
speaking of a friends of the show this
is wild so he's been working
on um skill housee which is this movie
with it's got fitty in it right and
Bryce
Hall dude has been working on this movie
for like
years here's the official Twitter
account now check this see what they've
been up to here's skill housee official
Twitter account reposting I have
reviewed the new Hunter Biden indictment
as a former Federal prosecutor and
someone who has followed the hunter Saga
quite closely here are my initial
reactions Hunter is in a lot of
trouble okay what is why is why is your
movie retweeting this
Ryan what the hell bro so good what are
you doing man this is how incompetent he
is he he's taken this this movie this
brand and now he's retweeting
like supercharged political on it
well that does that mean is the movie
just dead is it just is this just his
personal when did Bryce Hall come on the
show when was that good question was
that this year or was that in 2022 I
think it was about a year ago if I had
to guess maybe less I think it was this
year eight months yeah but even it's
been in
yeah
cuz we had already been hearing about it
yeah March 29th of this year so he was
talking about the movie at that time we
had heard about it before Bryce came on
too yeah yeah and they had like I think
it was actually shot several years ago
so it's just kind of like Sitting In
Limbo he's trying to sell it with
Casey's documentary they're both looking
for a a buyer what year is it that might
be be true you might be out to
sell the movie nobody's like I'm not
buying this
uh here's another skill house
retweet a breaking report a United
States warship had and multiple
commercial ships have come under Fire in
the Red Sea we're aware of reports
regarding attacks on the USS Canary and
Commercial vessels in the Red Sea and
will provide information I know this is
Ryan Kavanaugh because he's like a he's
like hardcore Zionist oh yeah like Giga
Giga Zionist yeah so like it was um this
is a cavcav
retweet to the extent that like wasn't
didn't he get mad at Natalie Portman for
not being like militantly zist enough
yes or something yes that was one of the
is leak emails right yes and his drunken
emails to Natalie Portman am right and
it was like all misspelled and when
she was like thank you I have to change
my email address now which as you know
is always a good sign when you're trying
to court
somebody don't ever contact me again my
famous my the best you could hear
really so I thought that was interesting
is there any updated details on this
movie well I I looked cuz when we saw
this I was like what the is up with
this movie and it supposedly has a
February 2024 release date oh my
goodness that's right around the corner
which a movie release in February is
that a curse I I'm pretty sure that
that's like where you dump the movies
that you know are going to bomb that's
what Studios normally do this is a great
uh comment if you look at Harvey's
Twitter actually that's Ryan
Kavanaugh oh if you look at uh it says
Harvey but I'll say Ryan's Twitter he
hasn't posted since December 1st first
non-movie retweet was on the third my
guess is he thinks he's in on his main
account at least he has another fail to
put on his toy podcast yeah I think you
might be right I think he's just signed
into to the wrong one yeah cuz why the
else would he be retweeting that
God and plus his feed would be like no
notification of like what account he's
on because the comments just make no
sense for the most part right because
they're all Bots probably it's just
jibber jabber this is the best of the
best Ryan wait
somebody I gotta I gotta see if this is
true but an enterprising young fan here
Gus in the chat says skill house first
mentioned an off the rails number
37 we're on like whoa over a hundred now
what what date was that how do you all
know that you guys are wild because
there's like these trans there's
websites where you can search like Mass
search the transcripts of are you
serious so good like yeah I bet you
could pull it up right now that's
freaking awesome yeah 47 right uh he
said 37 but maybe he meant 47 or maybe
there's an even older one do we have any
updates about his podcast too cuz I'm
also hyped about that I mean I'm a oh
good point I'm a big dropped the Pod you
know what was it called failure yeah
Ryan kavana failure a Ryan cavana
biography
autobiography nope still just the
teasers dude if he fails to launch his
failure podcast it's going to be the
best thing of course he will this guy
can't do any a goddamn single thing
right he cannot do a single thing
right we love him though has almost 300
ratings um five St when there isn't any
episode out it has four actually but
tough tough crowd
yeah um heralding from manifest media
the 24 episode series called failure is
set to launch in December yo let's go
day now let's go right now dude 24
episodes I'm gonna listen to each
one anyway shout out Matt R we've been
talking about a bit on the show
um he's doing the tour the Jordan
Peterson
show and we watched a bit of it it was
really quite a bad interview we were
joking about how bad of an interviewer
Jordan is he spoke I think was it 60 or
70% of the time someone did a breakdown
it's quite significant you asked for a
breakdown somebody yeah it was heavily
heavily leaning Jordan um but if you
look at the Matt R podcast I Happ upon
it and I was truly stunned let's
see here I guess his Matt's objective
was it's a modern TW was successful
because I mean 3 million views R
for
cancellation I haven't seen it I haven't
watched any of your stuff but you're
bold andilar and you're daring Brave and
you're so cancelled this is the oddest
dude Jordan Peterson heads are the most
brainwashed people on like this is the
oddest Most Beautiful Exchange there's
nothing beautiful about this exchange it
was just
vapid rambling of
Jordan it was 20 minutes Matt 53 minutes
Jordan it's so funny how's that for a
guess that's insane he spoke for over
double the amount of time dude uh what
is that ratio 20
20.04 25%
53.7 25
75 is it's a 37 Matt was 37% of the
podcast so about a third so about twoth
thirds of the podcast dude that's nuts
and he this is a comedian this guy talks
for a
living but anyway it's a beautiful
exchange and we love that about him but
anyway he's actually uh picking a new
fight now that he's taken women out as
just they're all taken out but now the
ultimate enemies here
six-year-olds um here he is responding
to a six-year-old's Tik Tok literally
com decided to start beef with my
six-year-old child online yeah you heard
me correctly my six-year-old child
online here's a comment he left wait why
is your six-year-old online
oh true dude right true posted a video
on her account right oh was on her
account my understanding can we see the
video that she posted I'm curious what
he maybe he has it coming maybe the
six-year-old was being really maybe he
maybe he was totally up anyway
Matt wrote this comment Jupiter also has
oh he was correcting about the Jupiter
Saturn ring joke he said if you want a
ring this ain't Jupiter or something
like that and everyone's like well
Saturn's the planet famous for having
Rings why wouldn't you say Saturn and
this kid Che dud into
him um if we can find
that I think oh lives she does okay so
here it is anyway he commented Jupiter
also has rings oh and Santa Claus isn't
real your mom buys your presents with
the money she makes on only fans good
luck and by the way I don't think this
woman is does only fans or maybe she
does I don't know I don't think
so that's a crazy thing czy kid is that
crazy yes hey your mom's a good
luck kid it's
nuts you heard me correctly my
six-year-old child on crazy think this
is the video he must have deleted his
comment cuz it's not on here anymore oh
he for sure did he got he got railed for
this one oh yeah people are saying in
the comments where is his comment yeah
Heely ered it Jesus man you really got
to get your together you don't know
me hidea means gift and this is my gift
to you reading Matt re to Phil like Matt
I have a full female audience online
although I like mine I don't want them
man you can keep them please I will
gladly take your audience because we
know you can't satisfy them anyways this
all started when his comedy special
which that's what we're calling comedy
the things he said that weren't even
funny were posted on Tik Tok and I
started being tagged in them because
everyone knows that my son is like a
genius and he's really into space I
fiercely protect my child online I'm not
a Family Channel people know his name
they know he likes space they know he
likes Minecraft and that's pretty much
it most people by this is
bunny hia bunny hia not know any
personal any h e d a y a about my child
and because of that and because I have
such a large audience when I see people
in person and when people see space
Clips they tag me in them because they
know that that's what he likes this is
the video that I posted oh good she
show because because Saturn has visible
ones that's why he said it has more he
clearly
knows s Rings trying to boost this a
little bit since it got so this kid in
his Universe hoodie comes down hard on
Matt and it has more also and you're
mean to
girls I love that he couldn't let that
go cutie he had to come on the
six-year-old it come over the top that
was really that's a w show oh really
well your mom's a
crazy bro the most beautiful light on
the other side of the screen and he's
got to break his spirit so quick it's
crazy it's awesome usually talks about
other people or other things for views I
focus my content only on me because
guess what Matt I'm interesting enough
on my own but I also didn't pay for my
looks so that's not really what people
follow me for you look to the video on
here you can see that all the comments
were like oh my God he's so smart he's
so cute like oh my gosh yeah you he's
not tagged in it
I have no connection with him and it was
posted on a Netflix page while you
clearly took a light-hearted video and
turned it into fighting with a
6-year-old let's talk about the comments
that you said about me this is my Ig
where he left the comment okay do I look
like I don't even show my body for you
to yeah I don't think she's only fans I
don't think she does any definitely not
I think she
does totally unrelated I mean she just
does like make and stuff it looks like
that's that's even more that's even
crazier like what she's just a why
cuz she's a woman online mhm awesome
joke bro super funny every single woman
online makes money by showing their
bodies true girl if that's what you do
girl do you like love it I have never
made a single dollar from a man audience
is female female female female and a
little bit of the Gaze and N you can't
girl me that people may like women their
personalities no you we know you don't
have one you stick to circle jerking the
men that you need validation from and I
will gladly take your female audience
you so desperately want to get because
I'm richer than you and
I to F it y let's go what now Matt r
lock on what's left of your career we
keep my child's name out your mouth we
can do unfortunately it seems like he
still has a lot left of his great he was
successful he got rid of all his women
fans and he went on Jordan Peterson got
3 million views and it was a beautiful
conversation it changed my
life
yeah that was pretty good I thought yeah
I was really good so hold on though
important questions
so can you clarify for me what the
argument about the Rings is over so his
joke yeah there was a joke about how a
girl was trying to get a ring on it and
he said something like uh Jupiter this
ain't Jupiter or something like that
right Saturn is the Planet that's known
for having a ring yeah I mean Jupiter
does have a small ring system but but I
think they're right I mean when you
think Saturn is clearly the one that you
make the joke about like what is that I
mean even uh Uranus has uh more rings
than uh Jupiter Saturn is the planet
with rings yeah I mean look at that
that's the one you can see the Rings
almost with your naked eyes it's not
even debatable bro what is he doing was
if you go to uh um Jupiter yeah I mean
it does have ring but it's not anything
like that look at that that's come on he
obviously I think he obviously named the
wrong planet yeah clearly you know I
mean you you can call this a ring around
you know what I mean I mean even again
even you're Ur Uranus here not a
planet not a planet they de you didn't
know that what they you're thinking of
Pluto dude oh which which one this plan
this is Uranus bro Uranus my bad it is
far out there wait Uranus okay it's a g
it's a gas giant it's definitely a
planet don't don't don't don't God we
got to get a six-year-old in you're Cal
yeah you're going to get F don't
dude don't roast me bro please uhoh I'd
be like thank oh hey kid anyway your
dad's
dead I don't know what the status of his
father for the
record um
so the kid is like yo what's the deal
why don't you say Saturn dummy I'm
stupid you know kid right he's right the
kid is right well and that's why I was
asking to clarify because if the if the
kid was speaking out of turn with
incorrect astronomy knowledge I might
have I might have switched up on him and
gone that side but no the kid the kid
had it he had had it
absolutely Jupiter also has rings oh and
Santa Claus isn't real your mom buys you
presents with money she makes makes on
only fans why would you leave that
that's so weird hinged what the
is his problem he's like the
villain from like he he this is the type
of dude would show up as like a
cartoonish villain in home alone or
something it's Mr burn yeah
literally the most bitter man in the
United States I don't oh that's so
funny Dan you're a smart guy you know
that's not how you pronounce Uranus uh
Uranus
no it's Uranus I think it's Uranus it's
Uranus it's your anus your mom's anus
let's see I thought it was
Uranus because Uranus is the gag right
it's Uranus yeah well let's do a
pronunciation let's see I got Uranus
Uranus telling you marus Uranus people
try and switch it up oh Uranus Uranus
wait Uranus okay cuz I used to say
embarrassed I used to say Uranus but
then I feel like I got yeah everybody
gets all like
[Music]
gunshy31 most people don't talk about
you're
yeah out of all the planets in the
solar system my favorite is your
it really is special it is a special
special
SP uh let's see
here Adore Me
update what's this one
about um oh God this was pretty funny
so you guys know I'm on a a war path to
uh sue people using
my my sounds for for commercial purposes
on Tik Tok yeah and I came across this
one I mentioned it briefly on the show
adore me which are they they do like
lingerie right stuff like that
mhm um
me do we have the original one I don't
know I I could I have it right now yeah
I'll watch it just to get brush you guys
up so I had you know I was like oh
Daddy's about to get
paid here it
is hi girl hey girl I see
you you know and so I the the person who
made it
responded this is the person asking
Ethan forgiveness and not to sue
please I am the adoring employee behind
the Tik Tok ad using Ethan Olivia sound
I was watching the episode yesterday
froze in my tracks when I heard Ethan
say Adore Me I honestly have no idea how
I didn't realize that sound was Ethan
Olivia and using it was a big mistake on
Mayan I've been a fan for years since
the H3 channel was still active and we
have some major H3 and Teddy fresh fans
around the office we come to you with
peace and love asking for Ethan's
forgiveness please I cannot end up like
Ryan
kavan we'd love to send the crew I love
that they censored it it's true it's a
slur we love to send the crew some stuff
as peace offering Olivia Sam Lena and
Ela I will make sure to hook you guys up
Zach is an icon so maybe I was just
trying to emulate him but in doing so I
flew too close to the
Sun PSS PPS legally I have to say that I
don't speak for the entire company well
I will say uh dear Ador me
employee if you know one thing about me
you know
this I never go against the
family I never go against the
family but one day I'll call on you for
a
favor that they may not come today or
tomorrow but someday it will
come and when that day comes I will need
you to answer the
call was you
Kish when that day comes
when the NRA is having a rally in the
town near you is that funny or no I mean
it's not bad just go int just go protest
it I agree I should protest them
man uh but anyway no I will not Sue you
uh I was going to send a legal letter
but I'm not going to with you cuz
we love you so hey girl not suing you do
they have stuff that the girls want
though you could hook us you could hook
the ladies up I don't know that's so
nice no yeah we are already gave our
size oh you did hell yeah that's awesome
so there you go thank you so much we'll
take that as a settlement thank
you never go against the
family
never
[Music]
um okay we talked about cupping I did
cupping in fact I'm still got cupping
scars
really right oh yeah yeah is that
c did you feel any different nah N I
didn't even feel the
where the crazy ass like uh bruising was
I didn't even feel anything or what
didn't even hurt nice it's better than
bad it is yeah is better than bad yeah
but here's where what I really need I
don't know if your god mother does
anything like this but this is the kind
of cing I think I need to take part
in oh was it doing this thing where it
doesn't play the
video it might be reddit's been funky
today there we go we got it check it out
guys thy to new extremes he believes the
bigger the cup than this is from did you
know daily USA the bigger the massage
and
relief dude that much fire has got to
create a crazy vacuum oh yeah cuz she
just used like a tiny little flicker
mhm bro didn't survive that treatment I
don't
think suck this Soul right out new
extremes he believes the bigger the cup
then the bigger the massage and
relief the bigger the cup the bigger the
massage e dude big
massage that's crazy that's a lot that's
a
lot so does she do anything like that or
therapy we could ask okay I feel like I
could do that for you I think yeah we
can figure it out just I me you just put
fire in it and yeah it's just like a big
cup of fire yeah I think so it's not
that I agree yeah
um oh Zach you're going to like this the
good
doctor the good meme machine doctor
there's new
ones oh man no yes there is I have to
refresh it every time can't can't do
this here add this one to the
repertoire you see this dude
the ultimate villain has arrived in the
show and Sherlock Holmes it's morotti
and the good doctor it's a pickle
no I said no pickles pardon me it's okay
they can just take that I said no
pickles oh I am so sorry I said no
pickles what happened to the bottle bro
I want to keep watching wait what
happened I know see what happened
happens man the bottle like executes
somebody like Decap that's what I was
imagining that it like shatters and
slashes someone's throat somehow I said
no pickles I said no I said no pickles
pardon me it's okay they can just take
that I said no pickles oh I am so sorry
I said no
pickles they cut it the best part oh no
I said you don't see it in the scene the
bottle like does like a freeze frame in
the air then it cuts to another scene
what happened though or nothing happened
nothing happened okay nobody died this
is a sad looking plate of food man they
cut to it real fast but this is like
firefest level like look at this
like one piece of lettuce half a
tomato whatever this thing is Chick one
chicken nugget sad sad I said no pickles
oh wait actually maybe there might be
more hold on that said that was a sneak
peek there was that they were building
up to some kind of injury the pickles
created a train a a uh chain
reaction that put somebody in the ER I'm
sure of
it I said no pickles
mhm I said no pickles I know man I
wouldn't I didn't do it I wouldn't never
do that to you the good doctor I would
never put pickles on your plate brother
ever I am a surgeon I said no
pickles yeah he's a good guy all right
so hold on we got to do the drick thing
and the uniform thing let's do the Dober
thing first and then we'll do the
uniform game sounds
good so this is really interesting
stuff um I found out about this from the
subreddit somebody there really got
hawkey because I hadn't seen about this
anywhere um State Farm is suing David
over Jeff's accident here it
is I said no pickle uh this was I guess
published two months
ago and we had to get the filing
actually my lawyer was kind and he he
went and got the filing and then kind of
even broke it down for me cuz I couldn't
tell if this was something interesting
grand for that n he's a no okay he
charged me that for other he he
actually I don't know he may have I
don't know you may have you never
know no
um I couldn't tell if this was
interesting or not because it's like
okay you know insurance companies sue
people all the
time it could just be a non but
it turns out I don't think it is a non-
nothing so here's what
happened David has an umbrella policy
with State Farm Insurance an an umbrella
policy is something I wish I had but can
never ever get because I'm too big of a
liability but basically what it is is
like an
all-encompassing
insurance uh plan that covers basically
anything that happens
defamation copyright infringement I
think is one it's just like it's just
umbrella it's got it all and it's I
guess pretty common for um public
figures to take out umbrella policy like
this now I wish I had knew that before I
started getting sued a bunch
now it's too late but now it is too late
does it ever like fall off your record
like in 10 years if you stay out of
lawsuits can you think you could get it
just for Life probably okay but at the
same
time I can definitely understand them
not wanting to Ure me they're like why
would I do that yeah what's in it for us
yeah
um nothing hap okay AB is confirming
nothing happened in the pickle bottle
scene okay I logged into Hulu and
everything it's nothing happen there
damn I said Nock really dropped the ball
or you might say the bottle in this case
y That's where love sent the freeze
frame work television is boring here's
the freeze frame so it actually did end
where the clip ended yeah it was just
describing bad cuz that went really high
up that could have definitely hurt
somebody and then it got to him in in
the medical office describing his bad
date so it's just a flashback no pickles
how was your date no
pickles I said no pickles no
no so anyway um so all we know is State
Farm is suing David
do here's what happened so yeah David
has the umbrella policy and so when it
came time to pay for Jeff's medical and
the settlement apparently from this law
suit that Jeff
has enacted against
davidan went to his insurance company
State Farm and said yo uh umbrella
Insurance got to cover this and they did
they paid out an undisclosed amount of
money and I do wonder I feel like it had
to be seven figures for them to come
after him like this I mean yeah cuz he
had like 20 surgeries on his eye so I'm
sure it all added up that's got it dude
that's a lot of guacamole yeah and then
the settlement I don't know what was in
that you know either right right
so the story is is State Farm Insurance
filed a complaint for declar declaratory
relief the complaint arises from an
insurance dispute related to a personal
injury filed against Jeff uh Jeffrey
Whit they say that they issued here's
the they issued a home owners's
insurance policy and a personal
liability umbrella the policies were
active during the time of the alleged
incident Jeffrey Whit filed a lawsuit
against David do alleging negligence
resulting in injury the incident
involved an excavator at Utah Lake where
Whit was injured after being swung from
the excavator the insurance claimed that
David do and his LLC tendered their
defense to State Farm under the
mentioned policies State Farm provided a
defense under reservation of
Rights State Farm cont ends that the
policies did not cover the
incident uhoh due to exclusions related
to business Pursuits and potential
workers compensation
eligibility Jeff was Jeff he was just a
dude though was in workers comp for
employees is he not considered an
employee of I don't think David ever
paid any of
them well that's maybe there's some
stuff they had ass signed because of all
the they were doing like maybe they were
under his company when they were doing
some of these stunts I don't know if
David made him sign something and didn't
have a safety officer there right that's
crazy but anyway they say it was not
covered under the umbrella policy not
just the workers company but they also
say related to business activities
whatever that means uh they're seeking
a they are seeking to be
reimbursed they're not obligated to pay
David
do uh defendant liability damage
judgment settlements or punitive damage
at all that arise from the lawsuit and
they want their money
back safe Farm has requested the Court
to declare that both the homeowners and
personal liability umbrella policies do
not provide coverage for the incident
and that State Farm is not obligated to
defend or indemnify the defendant in the
underlying lawsuit so this is pretty
juicy in that
uh David might be losing some serious
figures here to State Farm
Insurance this is very interesting I
wonder how this is going to play out you
know do you see the State Farm rep that
they sent no it's I dropped it in
Discord oh
oh no they sent they sent the wolf
Cody like a good neighbor I'll be there
in your good
neighborhood Cody from State Farm direct
oh Fu send WF oh no and wait for the
wolf who should be coming directly
although that being said I mean
insurance companies are scumbags too so
it could be frankly that it should be
covered by his umbrella policy I don't
know yeah but in the end I don't I think
they're both scumbags and so I
think I'm excited to see uh what happens
um but yeah pretty interesting huh so is
Jeff like is is Jeff liable for anything
I mean according to this lawsuit okay no
that's good not at all that's good yeah
it's all against Dober personally isn't
that great like that's he's got a
payback State form him dude although I
get the feeling he's making more money
now than he ever did with that Snapchat
100% um I definitely think so I
mean I think he's I think he's making
good money but I mean he was he had
Robert Downey Jr and his stuff he had
Leonardo Caprio chipot it was he was it
that's true and his his Heyday was
pretty
nuts um yeah je I mean David could none
of this would be happening if he just
took care of him he's being sued
by an insurance company State Farm these
guys are like juggernauts man they don't
around they sue people that's just
what they do on a daily basis that's
like their whole
business uh um so he summoned the
devil yeah they come
and no I'm they coming from docks the
pizza
spot or do yeah docks yeah I'm
interested to learn more about this
SnapChat stuff because it's kind of
interesting the way they have clickbait
and everything I've noticed with like
him and Aus McBroom you'll see like uh
like a a girl in a bikini it'll usually
be like Katherine and Austin's uh
thumbnail and they save it till the last
one so you have to click through all
their Snapchat stories to get there
smart yeah dude Austin is getting paid
by Snapchat and I can't get on that
program Austin MC broom that is wild
I've even speculated that he might have
like a contract to only post on Snapchat
because it doesn't really make sense why
he does David or Austin David I think
David just puts his time where the money
is he post on Tik Tok yeah yeah I just
feel like it's odd for him to not post
anywhere else well my theory is there's
no comment section on Snapchat
yeah send uh this was a nice comment
Jeff if you're watching um they're
saying Jeff is hot as he doesn't
need the other eye that's true okay you
look good with one eye Bry literally it
was honestly it wasn't fair that he had
both of them true he's too goodlooking
true it's an equalizing uh crime yeah if
we could just move one eye to the center
that'd be sick I don't know if the
technolog is there or what
Jeff
KS Jeff kops Cyclops yeah all right with
that being said let's get on with the
show um let's get on we are today we
are
competing whose uniform will
become the future the norm warn proudly
by members of the H3 podcast here
next year in our new
season I
mean we are making the winner right so
you want to make the winner and we will
probably wear them a couple times for
the for the G as long as we can until
we're like this sucks right we're not
doing just want to set expectations well
how long do you sit in the Scorpion
chair you know what I mean I mean
hopefully we won't do it as long that
was a couple years so I don't know if
we're going to be wearing these for a
couple years but but I guess it just
depends on how how Reviving it oh my God
Hold On Lena is this real oh my God wait
hold on hold on I can't believe what
it's just I'm working on something and
it's time sensitive hold on one sec oh
boy big news you want to read a maybe a
Dono or something yeah we got a bunch
here I'll uh let me check out uh a five
gifted p uh podcast memberships from
blizzard woy what are you doing dude
what are you doing the mods oh my God
man um let's
see uh Pearson donated 20 bucks and said
me and my girlfriend were supposed to be
at the live show this Saturday but the
airline changed our flight to a later
date without notifying us what how can
they do that the airline said there's
nothing they can do because it's basic
economy
ticket dude oh well that sucks ass man
I'm sorry that happened
why huh there's really nothing they can
do about that that's crazy how can they
just you like
that I'm very sorry to hear that I I
don't know what to tell you I feel like
you
should you should escalate that to a
manager or something uh cuz they they
got hold I'm I'm G to because I want to
ask Nina a few question okay uh I'll
keep going um no maybe no more male
guests over the age of 50
well yeah that's starting to look like
it might be a good policy change um
we'll think about
it uh Becca W said the show got me
through really hard years and I'm now
engaged in 12weeks pregnant hey Becca
congrats thank you for helping me hold
on to the good times you got
it uh Kevin Adam dtis oh boy I know that
name Kevin Ethan I'm still out here me
and shett have been hard at work in the
lab cooking up a response oh you know J
shett
of course he does call me Kevin um
stormy storm donated
$50 you need a professional body
language expert and interrogator from
the US Secret Service to help you
understand the intentions of Jay Shetty
my business partner would be able to
help now what is going
on that you have a business partner that
is a Us Secret Service
member are they allowed to like
Moonlight the Secret Service I don't
know but I would like a body language
person to follow me around and let me
know the
D well thank you stormy storm for the uh
$50
donation uh
Shades said uh take my illegal immigrant
money from my forever stagnant
job okay well thank you for the
donation uh if you are illegal just
remember no man is
illegal beautiful no man is a beautiful
or woman or anything in between
beautiful
um let's see Heidi donated 50
bucks and said petition to have a raffle
for Anson's box at the live show since
they're always out of stock and I want
one so
bad um maybe I can see if I I mean he's
he's always given us free stuff um and
I'm starting despite what Ethan says I'm
starting to feel kind of bad about it um
exploiting his generosity but yeah oh
maybe I can see what we can do with that
um but thank you regardless for the
donation and uh you know I tried to uh
go over to their little cafe over in
Beverly Hills uh yesterday but I didn't
realize they they close it 2 so I missed
my window said I'm exploiting their
generosity I said I feel like I I'm not
putting that on you oh come on I said I
know you don't feel that way why do you
feel bad we're this is a total I know
he's get he's benefiting from a of
course of course he is every time
chocolate we talk about it like Rave
about loss of it I know I don't know I
just I feel bad getting free stuff
that's just my personality we moved more
than Oprah okay seriously yeah no I feel
you we moved more than Oprah bro I get
it I get it he is definitely he's
getting something out of it too I I
agree
but it accepting them personally yeah
I'm the only one that that has any qual
about it oh stop damn he's very he's
always very nice about it though and uh
yeah Jeff's the man um his name's Mark
but so you good you get you handle your
time sensitive thing something ela's
birthday is tomorrow oh right and
there's was it what I thought it was
what you were talking about earlier what
we talked about shut up oh we'll talk
about it I don't know if it's a good
idea though that I think it's an incred
I mean we'll talk about it cuz it's like
so
much you know do it do it do it there
nothing that well that's um it's crazy I
love it it's one of those things that
you don't regret though that is very
true it just sucks for a while but then
yeah
yeah okay okay all right y all have to
wait to find out until after the uh the
surprise anyway anyway so let's get to
the um the crew
uniforms let's do it as you guys know
many companies have uniforms we're
talking about McDonald's Wendy's uh
Jiffy Lube Subway I don't know damn I
want
Subway it's been so long when's the last
time y'all had Subway you know what I
mean the beginning of the year when you
were silent for 10 minutes right it's
been a
minute shout out Jeff hot as with
one eye damn still looks good man no one
else could pull that
off um so we are we're going to go one
by
one
presenting at the
end the audience will vote yeah they
will be made
custom no expense will be spared yep and
we'll all be forced to wear
this which is fully you can I can force
employees to wear uniforms bro I can
force you guys can you I suppose there
has to be I think so I mean there's
plenty of jobs that require uniform so
yeah yeah I think I can force you to
wear a uniform I think so I can I'll
have to ask our HR mhm yeah I'll see you
on H3
snark he forces us to wear uniforms I
knew
it all right well let's do it I'm
excited excited to see everybody's I've
seen a couple but up first we've got
this
person I don't think we're not going to
do it anonymously because I think we
want people to talk about their design
okay so who's
first uh who is first who designed this
one that would be me all right maybe
take it away slick bomber jacket yeah
well it I'm not able to photoshop as
well as some of my colleagues but those
are supposed to be leather
sleeves I don't wear leather so already
a big strike against it and we we talked
about you know things could be slightly
modified if we decide we like it we can
get faux leather Dan okay down with the
faux leather's really good it's caught
up it's caught up huh it has that's what
I wanted full leather I would never love
the animals we love animals here folks
but yeah just like a varsity jacket
that's pretty cool pod squad pod squad
great for Branding oh brother don't love
the everyone in the office hates pod
squad the pod squad thing is rough man
they lack the vision they lack the
vision okay so that was a oh that's it
that's it just Jack the black squares
separated okay I mean it's cool I like I
like the simple design I like the color
choices we look like such tools though
if we all walked around in there I mean
that's going to be the case for all of
these pod squad pod squad yeah pod squad
assemble let's go disgusting I feel bad
cuz I recommended po squad for Lena too
so and now I look like I
cheated it's okay it's been floating
around that name all right thank you AB
very cool very comp comping
oh
interesting very nice who do we have
here that would be me okay
Lena what do we got the inspiration for
this one um it reminds me of like when
you're warming up in basketball and you
have like tracksuits and you can well if
you scroll down you can see the pants Oh
there's pants too mhm let's see B Squad
Squad yeah so it has the buttons on the
side rip it off I like the tracksuit
aspect yeah so if I'm hot or cold I can
mhm convert yeah quickly easy yeah I
love Breakaway pants MH those are so
cute thanks nice what we call this like
a it's like a track suit I guess yeah
yeah I dig it pod
squad we can work the pot Squad part up
next we've got that's
non-negotiable
oh this one got nuts what the
this is now this is a
uniform I wonder hold on what the wait
hold on is Taco Bell paying you or what
every location
really yeah there's a lot good there's a
lot yeah it's good to they even got them
up here like look how North bro I don't
even think people live up here yeah what
the crazy so go ahead you want to
unpack this for us well I figured like
it's good to have handy you know the
whole menu of um of the thing yeah and
on on the pocket there you see the
current uh like in item so that's their
campaign double decker yeah the double
decker they they're selling that right
now I find it so funny they selling
something called the double decker cuz
everybody knows that's just when you
in the water
tank but yeah you got all the little
campaign I need a double decker
and then double deck our toilet
yeah dude that's what's up um we got
little y Taco Bell dog there I love the
inclusion of of I mean I the the dog
yeah um and on the inside of the hoodie
there you and actually on the inside of
the whole hoodie you're going to have
the the like calorie for every uh every
taco and nutrition facts yeah the
nutritional facts you know some of us
want to stay healthy so for sure good to
know good to know so yeah and then the
other sleeves just menus and then the
pants here
so this is great but it it seems like a
uniform for a Taco Bell employee more so
no it's for Taco Bell enjoyer oh okay I
mean I am one of those so I think this
is I agree I agree you couldn't work at
Taco Bell in this that it's just you
know what I mean it's just the Vibes AR
right but if you go down to the pans
there's more lore on the left one you
see you see you have some um bundles you
can buy if you want to save some money
and the right leg there is actually a
homage to one of my favorite Taco Bell
items it's called the that's the crispy
chicken thing right chicken and like
samur I had one of those yeah what's the
sauce again it's like Chipotle Chipotle
yeah crispy chicken and Chipotle or is
it the creamy
jalapeno no that's not oh I I've never
even been here when they had a creamy
one yeah yeah yeah yeah so if if they
had a creamy one I'd like that too so
that's and that's like praying I want
that back you know uh cuz I miss it
that's quite Frank Frankly what's going
on here this is fire I I would wear this
yeah and then also on the left cheek you
have the you have uh like Los Angeles
and all that and on the right cheek
you have the the Eastern Seaboard seles
you mean the entire Western seaword yeah
I don't know Los Angeles that's on
the left that's Los Angeles on the right
entire Western half of the continental
United States New York in Florida that's
it okay yea partner did you remove Texas
it's in the it's ghost up in the crack
it's in the cck yep we don't need it
yeah actually we love Texas second state
right right right of enjoyers of this
love I like it thank you I'm there
anything Taco Bell makes you your
pants it Blends in a little bit you
won't be able to tell yep I I captain
who's this so this is mine okay wow what
the this is this is the bridge uh
this is the bridge team this is sort of
like a somewhat of like a you know
military vessel themed um I kind of view
this control room as as the bridge of my
ship in a way sure and uh why the pants
look like this that's kind of like a
classic style uh the top and tight in
the bottom yeah yeah I forget I they
have some weird name I think they're
actually like horse riding pants is
where they originated okay yeah and the
jacket I actually like it you know not
saying it's going to win but if we did
win we'd have to redesign a little bit
cuz this was I found some uh some jacket
that I thought kind of worked and then I
recolored it to uh to H3 colors it's a
Gundam uh inspired by the way okay and
you want to tell me about the boots uh
yeah what what about them what would you
like to know well how does it tie in
what's the utility what's the story it's
a full uniform what kind of uniform
doesn't have a regulation boots
the colors match they uh you know I'm
trying to coordinate Boots the house
down Dan Boots the house down like
freeza's boots yeah very good I think
they were I think I found them uh on
Alibaba as like a on like a cosplay
seller thing they weren't that color but
I I I took those and recolored them to
to work for the outfit very exciting as
you know here in studio we often need
boots for our work yeah uh so that will
be handy for us I think if you scroll
down I think there's a back too back
view yeah yeah an idea front and the
back so there's Dan yeah oh yeah people
are saying Jo jod Pur is the names of
those uh those types of what are they
called jod Pur dude what the J per
brain J per
brain all right moving on we've
got Olivia yes this one is sort of a
call and response go down we're with
stupid it's for post button moments
hi post button moments we can all just
get up and show our our t-shirts and
then so eth Ethan wears the Emoji one
and we all wear the arrow wow so we have
different outfits yeah we've got we got
different I have like the manager outfit
Captain Crew I've got the uh I've got
these Stripes yeah yeah yeah so I'm
wearing the happy face emoji and then
you're all wearing on this says I'm with
stupid we're with we are we're with
stupid we are right wow in the most
smart way possible coming down hard no
no I did I asked Dan I was like this
isn't mean right this is a
joke you said no this is damn I believe
I said yeah a little bit but it's funny
it's not mean it's not mean oh my God I
don't mean it like
that if we're all wearing it with the
arrows it's going to like yours will
just be pointing at me oh no the it's
all it's all custom we all based on
where we're SE oh my God the the arrow
goes yeah don't you worry it's going to
be a little bit special for each of us
Jesus
Olivia thought you liked me oh my God I
love are you kidding
me look at that look at that emoji this
one's nice that's the sweetest face I've
ever seen and I see you put a lot of
effort so that's
good okay off whites it is
funny little mean but funny I don't mean
exactly what I said said little mean
funny it's funny it's funny I'm the king
of mean but funny so yeah that's true I
can do it once I'm also the king of mean
and not not funny which gets me into
trouble some sometimes I'm the king of
intelligence king of amazing YouTube
podcasts I'm making for all right all
right all right all right thank you
Olivia it's not funny up next we've got
ooh Ian uh this is
yep
so this one was my sec I I I scrambled
to put this together this morning
because the one I made I looked at this
morning and I said this is the worst
thing I've ever seen in my life and I
got to just show you how bad it was cuz
I was like sending this to Olivia and
I'm like how bad is
this is it in here if he keeps scrolling
no I just send it a Discord this one I
laughed out loud just because I was
surprised it was a lot to see I thought
I was
cooking you were I'm OBS this here I got
it here I got it I got it all right here
was attempt number one from Ian wait I
like that one obsessed that's more yeah
are you kidding me wait that one's way
better I know I started second guessing
myself here I got some second opinions
that were not encouraging are you
serious that one is way better I love
this one you want to you can put that
one in you can enter that one well so
the other one I did is more uniform
style it's got the colors it's got the
there's two um embroidered patches on
the shoulders they don't push don't push
it's the for the button okay more of a
classic uniform and then we all get our
name tags I like the name tag aspect too
yeah that'll be a physical actual name
tag that we'll get done so let me ask
you this which one do you want are you
sure this is the one you want to enter
this one felt more realistic to me I
guess the other one is
y have a better shot with this one y'all
really pretending you like this I think
it's awesome amazing I love this Dan
what I'm talking about I mean it's it's
funny and silly the ugliest things I've
ever seen okay but like I'm not wearing
it to a wedding you get why I was second
guessing here I'm not going out to the
club in it you know Dan and some other
person as well
was I didn't say it was bad I said it's
a lot that's all I said that's a lot
it's a lot I guess I thought that was
kind of the point of this whole thing
yeah it's going to be cringe to actually
wear a costume that doesn't seem
unironic in my opinion so making
something crazy it's like okay they're
doing a goof right right if we're
wearing this then people like what the
yes like are they're going they're
a professional bowling team I like that
Vibe I don't know all right okay well
the people will speak yeah so this okay
so we don't we're not we're not
accepting the late entry this is yeah
I'll I'll just keep this one this okay
beautiful very
nice up
next
Cameron I like that a lot Motocross F1
f11 yeah I don't know about F1 but
I know it's got a letter and a number
just like us nice here's all the
sponsors that cancel landscap I we uh
are few and between but maybe we could
velcro those uh if we get take them off
as needed we could velcro those yeah da
Punk's cool so I threw in the helmet um
I love it are the shows as well yeah I
guess I I made this before
leftovers hung up the Jersey but yeah
you should probably make it yeah like AB
said just velcro all of it yeah yeah I
can the name of the podcast too right
yeah all right chill damn but yeah
that's the vi
there very nice very cool I feel like I
could fall off a motorcycle on this
let's do it be us and J Leno nice dude
nice that's
scam excuse
me I'm having horrible gird today she
fed in my
necky feeling gery now here's a
uniform oh Sam oh Sam did you seriously
give and you put forward a mesh top
listen there's layering mhm so we would
layer the tank top on top of the mesh
okay black parachute pants platform
Crusher Crocs with those jbits and then
no one else had an element of Teddy
fresh in their uniform mhm we will be
wearing that little Beret this it Teddy
fresh hat yes oh I didn't know that I
always thought you the wearing it
thought it was cool I was thinking we
could serf some CW word together I think
that you're exactly right this is
wild this is way crazier than the
layering you have to see the vision the
vision we're going to look like those
dudes dancing under the bridge I'd wear
that today tomorrow I don't know what
you guys are talking about I want this
now that's so true the shirt is kind of
like ice spice inspired how um she has
that um uh hot person at work shirt oh
you
know I'm sorry this is scary we would
serve we'd eat this I'd wear it if I
have to but this one scares me the most
of any of them I see your vision Sam I
like it I don't look good in
mesh I have never have we ever seen you
in mesh we have that's why Yeah we
actually have on the Jesse well thing
you were M oh yeah right right not
flattering to my
body okay Sam I see what you're doing I
see you very nice thank very scary Ian
your thoughts on this after the
criticism you faced look I think that
she's very talented and I appreciate the
effort she put in you hear how I said
that happy wife happy life oh that's an
example that's how criticism supposed to
or feedback supposed to sound Sam did
they not
eat did these guys eat they did they
ate I don't even see them in mesh man
there's definitely some mesh somewhere
right I see yeah I just saw my these
guys are
rule there it is there it is us next
year in our new
uniforms Vibes are everything man Vibes
till I die does it feel like this should
all be taking place at
night likeit the only guy in white is
all covered in blood this looks like it
shouldn't be taking place at all D yeah
fair but like if you're going to if
you're going to glow sticks pretend like
you're in the The Matrix and uh doing
glow sticks probably middle of the day
just seems like a odd time the glow
sticks don't really vibe in the day
true well
said um okay
Sam I see
you up next we've got Zachary
Zachariah oh the basketball shorts the
whole basketball Vibe so never go wrong
with
Hawaiian um thought it' beol I really
like the colors blue and
gold so I don't know I saw the vision
and I made it
happen it's like a
beautiful we're like little pieces of
gold in the sky so are we are we all
wearing the name sack I kind of funny
customized too it will be customized
yeah too but I want to wear a sack you
in the shower right now's that
noise Zach you okay there
[Music]
buddy no the audio was crazy that's all
yeah all right Zach thank you this is
this is and then we got the sneakers we
got the JS we good out here dude
the sneakers going to make this one the
most expensive yeah those those look
cheap how much what do these sneakers
run us are these exclusives depends on
the size but uh probably a couple
hundred
okay here's here's
us yeah it sounds like there's just a
plane taken off in the background it's a
good vibe here's Zach's
uniform that big look at the size of
that thing holy
smoke love Kos sa
attack um all right very good
very good is that it was that everybody
I guess it
was very
cool here's the
gallery let me pull this up so just to
recap
here we've
got AB with the bomber
jacket Leno with the joggers mhm Zach
with
the Hawaii
swag
mhm love with the Taco Bell
Chic
Neo Taco Bell Yo Taco Taco Bell hell
yeah
bro Ian with the uh gas station
attendant shirt this about right
yeah um a fun gas station beautiful gas
station Olivia coming in with the uh I'm
with stupid customize arrows pointing at
me from every
direction very good Sam is trying to get
me in
mesh goth Sam is trying or Cam is trying
to get me on a
motorcycle and Dan is trying to get
me onto the bridge of a spaceship yeah
where is Dan no not quite where's Dan
trying to get me in a Gundam in a Gundam
in a Gundam okay piloting a large robot
you know
Dan is trying to get me to run for the
uh governor of Florida with those boots
I wonder true would probably make a dope
one yeah I don't know if she heard about
it we I don't know if she gave we gave
her an opportunity I wonder what her
idea would be we can check in on Friday
yeah yeah I gave her heads up about that
we were doing this but she was pretty
busy it sounded like yeah she's been
slammed right the end of the year stuff
all right so we have a poll an off-site
poll this time because uh there's so
many options and it allowed us to put
the photos in there too so I am going to
pin it in the chat I really don't know
which is one's going to win I know what
I'm going to vote for right now and I'm
also going to spam it in the chat right
now oh you can do the pictures that's so
cool the pole oh this pole is awesome
yeah there it
is oh that's kind of okay so I know what
voting for but this could really go any
direction but I'm feeling this one in
particular let's see my vote is
in get to the polls people this will
determine Our Fate Rock the
vote Vote or
Die I think it crashed oh
no yeah I can't I won't even process my
vote are they think there's boss rigging
the election I think there's immigrants
in chat rigging our
elections yeah we got to not they're not
even members they're not even legal
members and they're vo
why what is okay it's so annoying I see
you put a lot of effort into this it's
not your fault Dan I'm seeing results my
page just refreshed you did
okay I mean this isn't that many people
they really they can't handle I mean I
don't how often do this so like just
have like 10,000 people coming to the
website at once at once at one time that
is a lot of traffic for one yeah for
sure for like just a ROM website that
probably has a couple hundred a day
yeah uh it's poll maker it's pretty big
their website is bro I can't even
load it anymore all right come on take
quiz-maker dcom oh it loaded for me it
just took a while all right so we have
do we have any
results well uh I can't well I can
probably see see the results once I vote
right I'm going to votee for myself I
did too so you got to love yourself I'm
going to be honest I voted for the one
that I thought was the cutest you voted
for mesh didn't you definely the mesh I
knew you were doing the mesh yes thank
you I just get a internal air when I try
to vote I am not meshing with the
mesh um I can't yeah the website
just well I didn't use straw Poole
because they always crack
I think it's more reliable than this
though
right uh I don't know this every time we
try and do a poll it crashes so maybe we
should just let members vote future how
do we control that Discord oh on Discord
we we just link on Discord
huh that would be that would def if we
get a sizable amount of people voting it
won't really matter if it's like 10,000
or a th000 probably if it's I think if
we did it in Discord we might get we get
a lot less maybe like a few hundred
maybe a thousand at most yeah that's
enough to I think so too I can't this
website is absolutely
nuked it did find it just loaded for me
finally so um I guess we'll come back
can't see yeah I guess we'll just check
in on it later we'll check back on that
later guys we'll see who's the big
winner I'll tell you who I keep trying
if you're in line stay in
line actually should we talk about who
we voted
for sure sure I mean sure yeah I don't
want to influence the vote but I'll tell
you I voted for loves oh well thank
you one yeah I think it's a it's a bit
weird and wild that's what I like about
it would you did you guys all just vote
for yourselves I voted for cam oh nice I
couldn't
vote you're not a legal uh member yeah
you have a green card no green
card all right all right we'll come back
thank you thank
you people are saying don't use Discord
we probably won't do that no I want
people to vote we just we just need to
figure out a way to Not Crash these
sites the real solution is YouTube make
their
better have more than four options on
YouTube um this oh did you guys know
Panera killed someone again I saw that
this is the second fatal from
their damn supercharged lemonade so
sad um Panera was just named in a second
wrongful death lawsuit over their highly
caffeinated charged lemonade we crunched
the numbers on this the last time I was
trying to figure out were they really
like um
negligent and so each cup of this
has 400 almost 390
milligrams of caffeine for comparison
Red Bull has
80 Prime energy has
200 and the I guess the problem is
somebody drinks this and then they get a
refill it's just lemonade you you could
kick back two lemonades in one meal for
sure and then you're pushing 800
milligrams that's a lot of caffeine
man um and somebody died and they didn't
they didn't did they change anything
about their lemonade situation they
released a statement saying that they
were going to be more explicit about
labeling the caffeine but I mean did
they ever do we they do
that that I didn't check I mean it it
wasn't that long ago that the first
incident happened so I wouldn't be
surprised if they hadn't finished
rolling out whatever updates they wanted
to do I feel like any San company would
just remove the product for the time
being right yeah well Panera released a
statement after the second death too
they did what they say yeah it's
highlighted in I'll read it but this is
all it says is charged lemonade I mean
it doesn't seem that serious they say it
here but it's easy to
miss I don't think most people would die
from drinking two of these but people
with health conditions I guess are at
risk
yeah hopefully that eliminates good at
least they went out with like enjoying a
nice drink refreshed I hope so too
that's all I hope uh quite sad though um
21-year-old Sarah Catz went into cardiac
arrest at Panera Bread Jesus she did
have an existing heart
condition same as the last person right
here she is she is the initial person oh
she was the first person she's the first
person oh Rest In Peace So Young yeah
man supercharged lemonade claims another
victim uh her lawsuit says the lemonade
was not uh labeled properly not as an
energy
drink
now 46-year-old Dennis Brown from
Florida his family has filed a wrongful
death suit after he died drinking the
lemonade
apparently here's a photo of dear dear
Dennis who is I think potentially even
in Panera enjoying a scrumptious looking
sandwich
although no this isn't
Panera is it this is like a iced tea
he's enjoying he's a he's a tea drinker
lemonade is in that category Arnold
[Applause]
Palmer so here's Dennis mining his own
business Dennis suffered from ADHD high
blood pressure and
chromosomal deficiency disorder the suit
says he would often avoid caffeine
Dennis's family suit states that Dennis
refilled his lemonade twice before
walking home
when he was found unresponsive after
suffering a cardiac arrest and
pronounced
dead Dennis suit also states that the
charged lemonade wasn't labeled
explicitly enough uh Panera bre released
a statement expressing Sympathy for the
family while Sly defending the safety of
his product the statement noted that the
company's investigation LED them to
believe that Brown's passing was not
caused by the product Panera
characterized the lawsuit filed by the
same law firm as the previous one which
made me raise my eyebrow a bit as
equally without Merit so here this is
interesting this lawsuit comes from the
same
people and I also do you think they
found him passed away walking home I I
don't know how can they put that on
the how can they put that on the
lemonade I don't know maybe just the
labeling part of it yeah if he has ADHD
and high blood pressure and he's taking
ADHD medication that makes his you know
his pressure even worse and then adding
caffeine to that it's a pretty deadly
mix I'd like to know the the facts of
the case they said he had two I'd like
to know the evidence is there a video of
him like slurping down two did we get a
blood Al a blood uh
sample um but don't you think it's a
little fishy that it's the same firm
they turned it into like a
definitely they're just like
oo did you they're running commercials
at 3 A.M do you or someone you love dyed
from Panera Bread lemonade call
us we specialize in suing Panera Bread
for people dying from
Lemonade they get very specialized these
days very
specialized uh but that being said I
think they probably got to have a case
because from what I can tell the
lemonade is still there and they didn't
change the marking on
it so I mean if and how many there's
probably got to be even more people that
died from it that never even made the
connection or or made the
lawsuit that sounds scary it is what it
is it is what it is that's what paner
bread
said it is what it is I mean you
know drink at your own
risk you know what they need to do
is add a skulling uh crossbones to this
yeah drink at your own risk risk of
death uh Ethan where did you I'm sorry
cuz I was looking into a little bit more
where did you see that it's the same
firm I read that in the statement here
it
says um it
says
family um statement noted that Panera
characterized a lawsuit filed by the
same law firm as the previous claim as
equally without
Merit have you or loved one died paner
bread call
us Todd and
Todd law firm in
Florida we specialize in canera bread
related deaths and we've won our clients
over10
[Music]
billion I we recommend sending you or
someone you love to paner bread and
drinking a bunch of
it
if you're injured or going into cardiac
arrest or
die contact
us we'll get you a bunch of money or at
least we'll get you some gift cards to
Panera Bread we'll either get you a
bunch of money or at worst we'll get you
some gift cards they'll probably do that
for
us settlements
today oh the okay so we have update on
the um the voting
yeah sorry I was m uh yeah so we have a
very tight race between Sam and cam here
a matter of uh just a handful of votes
wow every vote counts people um I will
say though we only have about 2200 votes
right now so and there's about 43,000 of
you watching right now so get the votes
some of y'all ain't voting get us in
mesh website is up well if I thought I
don't know why I thought yours would do
better just cuz it's so wild I feel like
people just wanted to see us in
something
crazy Sam is crazy though Sam's is
crazy I mean a lot of these are pretty
crazy Sam's is nuts man yeah you really
want me in a mesh toop girl why you do
that to me I mean cams is pretty
cool too though people yeah I've messed
with cams my problem with cams it looks
super hot I mean we always crank the AC
in here but I also freezing oh Cam just
took the lead as a matter of factly
I'm grateful for Cameron this is this is
maybe our closest pull ever 31 31 tiny
tiny margin here incredible vote with
your hearts I'm happy wearing any of
this stuff
so C seems to be taking the lead Cam's
taking the lead by 1% this is truly a
historic voting session here on the H
podcast let's go ahead and look down 10%
uh is third place Dan loves is closing
in nearly to 7% of Love No Love For
Love Ian getting crushed I'd love to
know how your other one would have done
Ian but they're saying no to
Ian's uh gas station uniform
6% Zach is getting creamed man I don't
know where's that coming from 4% for
four Zack can I voted for Zach I can say
it now Zach looks the most comfortable
yeah it does yeah for sure very cash
Zach your sound is although I bet Lena
would be comfortable too I the I like
the track suit uh Lena looks comfy 3%
come
on well I I mean perhaps we should have
done rang Troy
voting I wonder how that would have
mixed everything up well it I don't
think it matters Olivia's beating mine
Olivia's back she overtook Big Time 35%
to Cam's 33% 34% Sam Sam oh Sam took the
lead I'm sorry of these two I'd rather
wear Sam's just because cams look super
hot like I don't think I can K
me you this just I mean it's more Breezy
mine has temperature control it does it
does have that does
ventilation go down let me see the I
want the dang helmet though imagine
popping your hip in that Beret Ethan
sure yeah I can imagine it um Olivia you
what I I voted for ab I have less than
one AB why they hate yours so
much poor AB got 41 V like it's little
personal I don't know it's less than one
person I don't think it's personal come
on pod squad man I think it's the pod
squad the pod squad may have sunk you um
well Lena did
better right that one did not much
though frankly
right tough CP well there can only be
one winner I mean that's that's why I
was saying perhaps we should have done
rank Choice voting because you can get a
clearer sense cuz I think now what I'm
seeing is the gap between the top two
and everyone else continues to increase
and I think it's because people Psych
logically they don't want to feel like
they waste their vote on a low ranked
one and so they jump in on those final
two which is why the rank Choice may
have uh opened up some more options but
that's okay we we we we're sticking to
this I have a I have a solution for the
overheating too go ahead we won't wear
shirts and we'll unzip them okay wow
that'll be really cool oh that' be so
they call them dumps maybe we could wear
mesh under that too if we want that's
actually a really good idea so when I
sweat it'll just be sweat skin and
leather
you can't add stuff now I I'm I'm not
I'm taking away stuff if anything no you
added mesh oh I'm well if we want to
like you know combine the two I feel
like we can find a solution so at this
moment Sam is up by 2% which is
significant you know that's about a 100
votes at this time so I'm feeling pretty
confident that Sam is going to sweep
this we'll give it one more moment here
I really wish we could get that helmet
so
sick
bang each other we can run into each
other dumps head head button each other
be fun happy
Chuka to Sam whose uniform is going to
be winning here it looks
like very
good well this one I also thank you Sam
I feel like I could buy Sam's uniform at
like Ross for like five bucks you know
what I mean we're slaying on a budget oh
those Crocs look
pricey that will probably be the most
expensive part are those rare
Crocs no um I think I found them on the
Crocs website okay so that's good I'm
happy for you Sam but I was excited to
have a badass outfit yeah it's all it F
this isn't bad ask you you know we'll
see it'll be funny I don't know how long
it's going to last I don't know how long
I'm be able to sit in that frankly but I
wear it every day it's our uniform
right right until we
don't I want to go to gas station all
right I'm waiting for Dan to come back
to wrap it up but it looks like it's a
Sam dub so congratulations him I'm so
excited to wear that congrats thanks
guys you AB look
great absolutely crushed that man
crushed so let's see what else we got
here we got about 30 minutes
left one thing that I think could be fun
at this point in time
is the um the friend the ex- bestest
friend's PowerPoint oh do you want to do
that we can it's pretty short I I'm I've
been you know this has been getting
hyped up to me and I'm curious what the
heck it's all it the most silly most
Petty drama I've seen all year which is
just fave none of it matters the stakes
are so low it's just two ex-best friends
decided to air out their on Tik Tok
love that yeah so okay take walk me
through it yay
okay did you pull it up uh-huh okay
sweet the girlfriend the best friend the
boyfriend the hoodie and the
sandwich Petty are fave all right so
many moving Parts literally so let's
start off with the definition of petty
of little importance trivial secondary
lesser importance therefore no one
should go harass either of these
girls no harassing zero we don't buy it
we don't believe in it we are grateful
that these girls gave us all of this to
we thank you guys for serving yes we do
so this is just you know a Stakes graph
in terms of like whether or not the
stakes are high they're not they're low
don't harass these people now let's get
started what is the commodity variety
line you
know what does that mean oh you don't
know okay no I was I thought I was like
yo this is a new way thinking about
things I've I mean like we talk about
in in theater we talk about Stakes all
the time and my my professor would
always reference the Stakes chart but I
actually never once this is a real chart
yeah I got this on Google Images so what
the is commodity and variety how is
those separate how are those
opposites
Dan I just got back from the bathroom
what are we talking about am I looking
huh Sam one and now we're doing best
friends power point oh okay all right
whatever here's the cul fruits okay so
these are the players Kelly is on the
left Kelly's boyfriend in the
middle Joanna on the right
okay very good this is Kelly's side of
the story this is the video that came
out first but not the one that popped
off initially so when this one went out
it was like to a smaller pool of people
talk about interesting so she started it
thata to be a girl didn't say her
friend's name for
oh all right let's hear what Kelly has
to say about this yeah yeah go ahead
Kelly get ready with me while I talk
about the ridiculous things that this
girl that claimed to be a girl girl has
done to me for contacts I've never ever
in my life had to cut out a person cold
turkey and I've never had to go through
a friendship breakup because genuinely I
feel like I only open up to the people
that deserve my time and I end up loving
them for a lifetime hopefully but this
girl was just an exception I am going to
try my best to talk through all of this
without freaking raging the first one is
not that bad I guess compared to the
other things that she's done
but the day that she met my boyfriend or
like a couple days into it she added in
to her close friend story and just
started posting the random tmis on her
stories like a attention so so her
theory is that she added his boyfriend
and then was posting for him that's what
she's saying that's pretty presumptuous
but people do that I mean yeah it is
pretty presumptuous I'm not I guess I've
never used in terms of Instagram I never
use Instagram as like a normal like just
person I mean like I used to some people
Flirt by putting people on their close
friend story I think it's just like oh
we are friends and I'm letting you know
that like I want to be friends yeah like
I would put my friends boyfriends on my
close friends I think I do I don't have
a a close friends list but I'm always
flattered when people add me yeah I
think you're on my close friends list oh
yeah I think I've seen yours an honor I
like those ones I love those ones I
always click the the close friend ones
you never look at my story I always
check you do it's always yeah how do you
I checked for close friends wait how do
you tell how can you even tell swipe up
I see I see on the close friends who's
checking it out are we close friends
you're on my close friends I don't know
if I'm on I don't have a close friend
list okay well you're on mine hold on
Cameron you just get exposed I don't
know why cuz usually I all you guys come
up at the top of my list I here all
right let's take a look here I oh you're
with my boy
alex what I see I'm looking at your
stories now oh oh yeah with Alex well
there's no close friends right now I
can't see well I just looked at all of
them dud oh thank you so much and I'll
be back that's good thank you I'll be
back I'll be back I look forward to your
return cuz you so here I see loves at
the top of my pile but Instagram's been
you over
Dude I must have done something to piss
off the Instagram
God all right go ahead I guess I did
something toiss off the Instagram giss
off the Instagram
gun not even a thir oh is that what
happened I see what you did Ian talk to
you soon The Ellen thought of
[Laughter]
just trap and this was before my
boyfriend and I started dating but like
everyone knew that we were into each
other this one kind of goes with the
first one she borrowed my boyfriend's
hoodie when we're all over at his house
cuz she was cold and then she took the
hoodie home which is fine girl like okay
I'm already saying like this is really
you didn't need to make this video at
all
right like this is some like really
normal type of Life interesting be
warm but I hav but I'm standing by and
standing back and standing by m m like a
don't get cold but she continues to wear
that hoodie for the next 2 weeks and
posts all about it on social media a
picture of her in his hoodie which is
again I can let it pass whatever starts
to randomly show her love for the brand
that my boyfriend likes never this girl
brag about how much she likes this brand
all sudden she's wearing Nike or some
dude she started wearing Nike dude
I actually feel like that might that
might be the brand it need it depends
how Niche it is she talking about Adidas
talking about Nike then come on give me
a break okay go on never until she met
my boyfriend spending hours getting
ready to see him hauling up my other
friend telling her that she thinks he's
cute and that she could see herself
getting along with him one thing to
point are they dating yet they are not
dating yet yes they are she said they're
not she said before she said no no no
she's about to say when we are already
dating okay if you just for this part
okay okay okay go ahead while we were
already dating getting him the sandwich
that he mentioned he likes and then
volunteering to wake up early so that
she can hand the sandwich to him so that
he can take it to
work I'm kind of surprised right now
because now that I'm talking about this
months after I don't know how y'all
ladies do this this device is terrifying
yeah it's torture it is I use it every
day like I know I I can't I don't know
how you ladies use it or whoever uses it
one they will teach you everybody who
uses it it you can't just sit there and
casually use it like that's like it
doesn't look psychotic it does look like
a torture device so scary first time I
saw it I saw my mom I was like what are
you
doing you
okay okay
Mom happened I find this hilarious I'm
not even raging anymore I just think
it's kind of funny how hard this girl is
trying honestly I don't blame you girl
my boyfriend is cute just hope you can
find a new man to buy sandwiches for
every morning goodbye and I wish you the
best interesting so I think the the big
question I have is when they started
dating because she mentioned in the
beginning we weren't dating yet then she
mentioned some here in the back we were
already dating I think the first night
when they met that was probably the
night that they all met him for the
first time and then they all went back
to his place so they were all new
friends but her bestie was about to like
date this guy but she also probably
thought he was hot maybe so after that
night she was like I'm going to put him
on the close friends cuz we all followed
each other but like even though my
friend is the one who's like pursuing
him cuz she you'll see in her video she
did bring them to talk to each other
this whole thing where it's like
when have I seen I've seen this in
reality shows I don't can't remember
what but it always seems so juvenile
when it's like you knew I was into him
how could you talk to him it's like
Well everybody's single you could
nothing was happening he's just he was
he's clearly not into
you you know what I mean we got to live
our lives yeah I think Girl Code it
really depends on um the context cuz
sometimes I do find it
a bit of a betrayal when I like watch
stuff like this
happen this a girls girl thing yeah if
someone really does know and
they and they pretend not to it's not
fair cuz like let's say two friends
you're in the same class with a guy
M and let's say you both independently
notice him and you like him you're
interested whatever your friend you
probably sit together true and so he
comes and he interacts with you guys
then when you you get home or a week
later or whatever one friend is like I
am so into him but the other girl was
already into him she just didn't say it
so what so what is it like tap tap no
seat back like I think um you know
it's just not fair I think yeah based on
this story it sounds like those like
those two were feeling each other the
boyfriend the girlfriend and then like
it was just clear but that is also her
side of the story but in the next video
which is the next slide she does explain
that she brought them to one another and
was like you guys should interesting
yeah next video is revolutionary so this
this was just a normal video yeah I was
kind of on her side in her first video
but when the second girl dropped the
video I was like oh
girl this really changed everything
there was there was some stuff that she
conveniently left out that was like this
specifically with the sandwich the
second or the first well let's watch
girl that's
some I don't know what you're talking
about no that's what I'm saying just be
prepared here's
Joanna her side of the story whoops this
is her side of the
story Girl speak this is the one that
blew up let me interesting everyone CLE
some misconceptions very interesting
okay that people are having online about
me so I don't know if you saw the video
yet but there is a video about a girl
talking about why she ghosted a friend
and the reasons behind that and I am
that friend that's been ghosted and it's
just so baffling to me that I had to
find out this way when I have reached
out so many times desperately asking you
what was wrong the points that were made
in this video three points that I
remember close friends let's start with
that she's saying that I was trying to
get at her boyfriend whatever because I
added her him on my close friends first
of all close friends don't mean a lot to
me and it was not only him that I added
it was everyone that I met that night we
met at a club together on my birthday
and she whispered to me thinking that
there was a guy over there that she
thought was cute that's what that's what
I said is her birthday it's her birthday
party but like it's not fair to be
like cynically a girl could be like oh
I'm so into him and then it's like
nobody's allowed to pursue no that
that's different I think if the if your
friend meets him first and she's told
you she likes him obviously dibs if you
and your both think someone's hot if
they're clearly more interested in one
of you I think it's like an unspoken or
spoken like you and your girl can like
go to the corner and be like I think he
likes you better like it's cool but it
doesn't sound like they were good enough
friends to even have that
conversation okay let's see let's hear
as her best friend I'm going to play
Cupid I went to him and I was like hey
my friend thinks you're cute you guys
should chat it up they chatted it up
ended up going well so we went back to
his apartment
with him and his friends and me and my
friends so we all kind of be her
birthday like just comfortable with each
other and obviously if I'm comfortable
with you I'm just going to add you to my
close friends it's really not a big deal
the attention traps I don't know what
she was referring to because if it was
attention traps like why would she also
be on the close friends if I just wanted
that to be attention trap I would only
add guys I'm trying to get a I I don't
know but I post thst trap on my public
story so that everyone can see that um
the hoodie I'm just notorious for not
giving back hoodies and I am sorry I
just took longer to give this one back
because it was really yeah no it's done
what she's notorious for stealing
hoodies what do you don't like that
what's happening Dan what do you mean
explain your you can't you can't steal a
man's
hoodie well you can't what's the cont
how did she get the hoodie the she says
that she was cold she says I'm notorious
for not giving back hoodies that it's
done but she says what do you mean it's
done she's the villain is that what
you're saying okay she's a hoodie Ste
that's villain Behavior who does that am
I crazy no you're not you're not crazy
at all my question is why do people keep
giving this girl hoodies and like she's
Ser she's conspiring and then here what
she says is it was so I liked it so much
I didn't want to give it back like
excuse me that's called theft
not you know glad to hand them over
especially in college which I assume
these people are in this these these is
not hoodies good hoodies are not easy to
come by you that cost money
mhm we do find out what the hoodie
looked exactly like soon okay that's
good better not be a nice hoodie I'm
going to FL don't you worry
we've got we've got all of the data all
right so go on this is intriguing go on
go
on penion trap I would only
add guys I'm trying to get a I I don't
know but I post thirst trap on my public
story so that everyone can see that um
the hoodie I'm just notorious for not
giving back hoodies and I am sorry I
just took longer to give this one back
because it was really cute it's not
because it was many girls over the years
have stolen my hoodies are you kidding
me is there a specific one you miss that
you think
about hold
on I have to say if a girl is going to
steal a guy's hoodie and wear it I mean
the hoodie thing it it's not meaningless
it it smells like him yeah I think it's
endearing it forces him to contact them
to get it back yes or or leaves the door
open for them to contact him and say oh
I have your hoodie it's not it's not
nothing here's my
question if I had a boyfriend and my
friend took his jacket and continued to
wear it for like weeks I would probably
be like what's the posting photos in it
too like what's the
deal because that's that is straight
girlfriend Behavior but they weren't
dating yet no they were were they it was
the first night she got the hoodie when
they said they just met yeah she said
that they were feeling each other and
they I mean they continued obviously to
see each other in date I watched this
when it came out but I think the boy
offered the hoodie up very very broadly
she offered it to him she didn't ask ask
for it right but she still didn't give
it back for weeks well and her friend
was like dating this guy I think just
keep watching this is interesting and I
would say on the guy's part usually not
not all the time but usually the G the
exchange of a a warming garment an over
uh outerwear is a sign of a flirtatious
sign not
always but a lot of
times longer and like I just wanted to
feel cozy up in his hoodie it was
literally because it was cute the
sandwich you were feeling cozy up in his
hoodie I don't know if I can discount it
so easily we also don't we find out
about the boyfriend later okay okay okay
is like the most iconic part of the
story um you and I both know babes that
sandwich was an expression of my
gratitude for mounting my TV what oh and
at this time like the sounds like the TV
is not the only thing he
mounted hold the phone there's a
big Revelation hold the phone bro okay
on living together me and this I I can't
missed a second of this you're right
Olivia this is
good iic part of the story um you and I
both know babes that sandwich was an
expression of my gratitude for mounting
my TV oh and at this time like we were
living together too me and this girl we
were living together we roommates um so
they were together we were us three were
together in my room mounting the TV and
like making jokes and making fun right
and then like I really wanted my TV
mounted and he did it so I was like oh
my God like I'm so thankful let me show
my gratitude in some way other than just
being like thank you so I picked up a
sandwich um after work at a bakery
that's right next to my work and I put
it in the fridge and I was like okay
perfect we have a sandwich secured for
you come pick it up before work tomorrow
so you can eat it before it spoils cuz
why the would I get you a sandwich
and have it why did you buy him a
sandwich you created a chore for him
that is I mean that is an that's not a
thoughtful gesture at all she's like hey
just so you know come by first thing in
the morning cuz I bought you a sandwich
for no reason that you need to
eat it is interesting it's kind it's
nice it's nice to get him a sandwich it
would be nice if like I was there and
she's like hey I brought you a sandwich
but she's like I bought you a sandwich
come get it and at 8:00 a.m. I'll be
like what the yeah no thanks I'm
good yeah it's interesting not hungry
I'm I'm good thanks she came with him to
pick it up I handed her the sandwich if
I really cared about like me getting him
the sandwich because it was like for him
I would have wanted to hand it to him
well you didn't have a choice it sounds
like she removed that option from you
I'm not trusting her at all I don't I'm
not trusting this girl care it was just
a form of expression I would have done
this for anyone else it doesn't matter
that it was him left the friendship with
the other girl
together and villainized me and now one
year later you come on Tik Tok to talk
about it is so low and why am I blocked
no I literally saw the video yeah
exactly you didn't even you're outing
yourself may maybe a lot of their mutual
friends know the story so more about
like their local uh reputations that's
fair commented and I said let's not
leave out details why'd you delete the
comment I'm I'm sick of staying quiet
I'm sick of having to hear from break
your silence
girl I will no longer be silenced people
I heard this about you from her
respected that you had your own
perspective on things but now that I
know this is the
reason I'm so glad that you're not in my
life anymore okay okay well I got to say
I think the first girl had a
point something she forgot to mention
which I thought was the biggest deal was
that when she was dating him she told
their friend I think we'd really get
along me and her boyfriend and I think
he's really cute where did you get that
she said that in the first video and
this girl the first one Kelly said in
that video that when they were already
dating she said to one of their friends
Joanna said to one of their friends I
really think I could get along with him
and he's really cute that's hearsay
though that is hearsay but it's
something that we didn't add and she
said were three major parts of that
video she can remember and it's like if
my friend said that I said that about
their boyfriend that's the first thing
I'd want to clear up she did not dispute
it she did not she not address it she
did not even address it all right so
what do we have here the close friends
sandwich and the hoodie the sandwich the
hoodie I think close friends is the
least important I think sandwich middle
important I agree hoodie most important
agreed yeah Dan right Dan I don't know I
don't know if I agree in that the
sandwich one was pretty personal you
think like the hoodie because like you
can give a outerwear a jacket a hoodie
to a friend and not necessarily for it
to be romantic but the sandwich thing
the fact that she kept the hoodie for so
long and posted in it she said that she
kept posting in the hoodie they live
together that's what's so confusing
that's I don't I don't fit that in into
things the boyfriend he's kind of a
catch oh yeah is he a honk we'll see
what I haven't seen the what does that
have to do with it it's just like
some
sometimes your heart your
heart so hot that he he drove this woman
insane into stealing his hoodie he had
to she had to get him a sandwich all
right so here we have the hoodie reveal
so this is well this is his girlfriend
yes the first girl yes okay first girl
wearing the hoodie yeah after both
videos went viral she posted making this
cute hoodie or like styling this hoodie
she got the hoodie back eventually
yes okay so she's she's trying to show
the world the hoodie that's the super
cute hoodie she didn't want to give back
okay oh yeah Nike Swoosh it is
was Nike yeah but then the other girl
okay that makes the other girls claim
silly cuz like oh she was wearing Nike
all the sudden it's like what he would
who would even notice that true well we
don't know if it was Nike it was just
that was a a guess all
right think we have to mute guys oh wait
got it
sorry okay so here she's styling the
cute hoodie she's showing all the
different styles that a hoodie and how
do you know that this is the hoodie
because she she said styling a cute Hood
it went viral everybody it's the
hoodie it's the hoodie it's the hoodie
it's known it's common knowledge yes
yeah it's literally household okay okay
and then this is the boyriend so hot so
when all you're driving these ladies
crazy bro when these photos dropped all
the comments changed and they were like
oh Joanna girl I get it I get it Joanna
Jo second girl yeah Jo the second the
best friend you're like I get it girl I
get him a sandwich
too I still don't
think you you're still trying to steal
your friend's boyfriend and and more
importantly stealing his hoodie abs and
also this is ridiculous they lived
together and she just had the hoodie up
in like her room or whatever yeah it's
like how hard is it to just like hey
here here's the hoodie back yeah it
sounds like they should not have been
she's thoughtful enough she's thoughtful
oh he mounted the TV better get him a
sandwich and make him come over here at
8: a.m. but I can't hand him the sweater
he was she off Jesus Dan's taking
this
personally she was trying to get in on
that I feel like there's no question no
question but the the sandwich thing I do
think I I tend to think the first girl
is right when watching it again but why
would they come and get the sandwich it
makes me think that they maybe are
literally neighbors like house they live
together no no no the boy the boy and
the girl came together to the apartment
where they live to right that's what
they said right maybe she like spend the
night or something but there's no like
no one in the right mind would go and
get that sandwich right they they must
have been very convenient for them it's
like hey you lived on the hole do you
guys want to bring this sandwi
suggesting they maybe lived in the same
building I'm not necessar I am still
siding with the first girl but it
doesn't make sense you had a you made a
good point if his girl yeah I think that
was you Olivia if his girlfriend lives
there he could have been dropping her
off been coming to visit and they could
have hey grab the sandwich on anyways so
that maybe minimizes the sandwich thing
a little bit but I think as a whole I'm
still signing with the first girl this
this no but like it's the fact that she
got it and she's like come get it
tomorrow regardless of how it played out
that's a huge red flag to sandwich I
think yeah if I wanted to thank my best
friend's boyfriend I'd probably give the
sandwich to my best friend to give to
her boyfriend just because you and you
listen when it comes to the like
significant others of your friends you
there's you you want to be mindful of
not even being perceived as Crossing
certain boundaries you know
sure she wants it
it that's for sure wait is this it yeah
oh that's it and that's it it just it
caused the internet to have like the
loudest discourse I've heard since uh
what's like another crazy viral
story did they not Haley versus Selena
the last one that you told neither of
them made a followup I was hoping they
they each could keep spitting um these
were the super big moments I can give
you a little uh update on Wednesday if
you want also the boyfriend have any
statements you know I'd like to hear
from him all right I can I can put
together a little thing for you could
clear this all up if there's updates
that'd be terrific okay for sure all
right well listen that was fun yeah good
time that was great that's what I live
for that's why I come to work yes I love
the petty drama I love that you love
it I don't get that stuff on my homepage
I wish I did it's just Jade cutting and
I do like that the stakes are very low
in this in this drama those are my
favorites low sakes drama true what's
couch guy everyone's saying we talked
about that right yeah yeah yeah the it
was a super viral like a year and a half
ago maybe where a girl or a a boyfriend
or her girlfriend went to visit their
partner at College it was the girl went
to visit her boyfriend and when she
walked in her boyfriend was sitting on a
couch with a girl and like people were
totally just trying to figure out the
body it was the body language talk about
it on the show we talked about on the
show yeah didn't like what did we decide
it was sus I mean you look at the photos
look at
this right and he like snuck the phone
away or something remember oh yeah he
was that dude was guilty as yeah
yeah no look her face there yeah
exactly videos unavailable we are hiding
the details people all right listen
thank you guys for being here oh let me
think the Dono is real fast we got a
list going yeah uh yeah if you go we
have a channel for it now that been
dumping them in oh good here perfect
send it like that yeah it's filtered let
me see where does it start here Savvy
code per Ethan's request wrote some code
for the Matt R Jordan Peterson episode
oh this is wait no that's
old oh okay
cool thank you to Kylie crumb it's my
birthday 33
Zach hit her with it give it to her come
on put the kaios on that I know but it's
the SE is the season I think Zach's
gone or he's lost in the void he's
trying to talk but he's in the he's in
the dark place Z Zach are you
okay what you're good you're good you're
good happy birthday uh Kylie Tiffany
solivan says it's my 32nd birthday oh my
goodness we're getting younger anyone
31 9466 thank you for the 20 gifted
that's very generous and very nice thank
you so much Dan SW love
too who's that it's the sequel
man the sequel's Never As Good As the
original oh I've been seeing them in the
chat they have a uh a uh it's PMP but
with like my face
on PMP in like the famous Let's Go photo
and their name is just Daniel love 2
okay I like the dedication yeah they
don't they says uh I can explain
referencing the Taylor Swift pick oh
great right all right um and I I feel
this am mandz thank you sorry this is
late but I live in Chicago and I've been
working with the newly arrived
immigrants they have nothing most of
them sleep on the streets in tents in
the freezing weather yeah dude there's
probably not not many places in the
world as bad at least where people live
as bad to be as Chicago during winter
being homeless in Chicago it's like a
death sentence super cold there they
have they have too much says Joe Rogan
yeah why do they have
why but shout out to you for do out
there yeah you're you're you're one of
the hero
definitely uh vonella says my
boyfriend turned 26 today Noah and five
years sober we love that we love sober
Kings oh professional douche wait I
wanted to talk to this guy we had a
didn't we have a line up to talk to him
I trolled Matt Gates into public
accepting a fake award to raise
awareness to the allegations against
them do we have uh receipts on that I
have email with him let me see I've seen
one of his videos I thought it was
pretty potentially funny or
interesting he's Fearless I remember
thinking this guy is like does not care
about his safety at
all well look into that for Wednesday
professional douche perf I just emailed
him great uh Vana Olsen hi everyone on
the HB crew and Ethan just want you guys
to know how much I appreciate you guys I
have kidney failure stage five just like
Shredder and basically live in the
hospital oh no
are we working on a transplant I
hope is there stage
five I guess does it stop in four in
dogs there is stage five end stage
kidney
disease
huh
we got to get you a new kidney
anyone got anyone going spare on a
kidney cam you good with that we're
gonna get we're gonna give her one okay
I got two so I don't need know I'll give
up one of them that's true yeah it
I'll hook you up I'll take care of
you I'll pay for one of I'll pay for
just your first medical visit David
Dober
style does anyone want to go half SE on
a kidney half of mine half of somebody
else I'll give you a tenth 10th what are
we all pitching well that's nice does
that work can we Frankenstein and K
together for them oh yeah I that works
that way last I heard somebody gave
somebody a kidney they ended up hating
them right yeah the Selena thing but
we're besties again oh they're back yeah
they posted for each other's birthday
dude you better NE you can never be mad
at the Kidney donor you know I think it
was it was the opposite way it was the
the Kidney donor was upset with Selena
but they mended things thank God wait
did a fan give her no bestie a best
friend and then they had a out after the
kidney transfer that's
up but we're back we're back all right
we're so back mallerie Bugala says Ethan
I was pregnant when Ela was pregnant
with Bruce it was so so fun comparing
fruit sizes with her you helped me
through postpartum and my daughter's
almost two now it's awesome I love that
yeah Bruce is almost to it's so exciting
such an awesome age isn't it so sweet so
sweet so
cute it's so nice so congrats love that
and thank you to everybody for watching
for being here this is our last week of
show leading up to the Fantastic special
we have this uh weekend I am playing do
not get sick that is the game I'm
playing this week I not going anywhere
I'm not doing anything with peace and
love of course do not invite me to your
event peace and love I will not
go the first time I was sick and it was
just
horrible and the second time there was a
illness scare I
think peace and love crew thanks for
keeping us entertain me and Ela share
birthdays happy birthday to you tomorrow
and
N all right guys so listen um Tuesday is
ela's birthday so I will not be um doing
a member stream tomorrow I'm sorry about
that I'm going to be taking Ela uh and
and her mom for a fun I have a fun day
planned oo it's going to be nice cool
but um like I said I'm making it up to
you guys because we're doing an EP an
extra Epis episode this
weekend The Big
Show YouTube's sexiest night get ready
guys and I guess I'll just say it again
to say it if you are coming uh dressing
up fancy is highly encouraged but not
required not required not required at
all but if you want to get into the
spirit of the night come uh come in a
nice suit come in a nice dress whatever
you got and uh we'll have some fun
absolutely um there will be a sound bite
tournament on Friday somebody asked oh
yes Friday's the big day I'm excited
that's what that's one of my favorite
episodes every year that is always a
good time so we'll be back on Wednesday
for an episode we will be on Friday
we'll be our sound bike tournament and
Sunday's the live show guys thank you
everyone for being here love you all so
much have a Jolly Jolly Holiday time
every
night it's December for pizza's sake get
out there and have a jolly old time uh
It's Beginning to Look it's be what's
the PA McCartney one that everybody
hates Simply Having a
simply Wonder chras
time all right thanks everybody see you
on
[Music]
Wednesday
n